[Musique]
Messieurs, bonjour. Nous vous recevons
pour une chaîne internet qui s'appelle
Syerview. Nous sommes en direct. Pierre
Noisa, bonjour. Sébastien Gouspio,
bonjour. Pierre, est-ce que tu peux te
présenter succintement ? Bien sûr. Euh
donc je je suis entrepreneur fondateur
de Premium qui est un exchange Bitcoin
euro donc qui permet aux gens d'acquérir
et de vendre des Bitcoin. C'est un des
premiers au monde, c'était en 2011. Euh
et je suis ingénieur de formation,
polytechnicien, voilà. Et aussi auteur.
Euh j'essaie de de partager mon ce que
j'ai pu apprendre au fil de l'eau sur
bah plus récemment l'énergie puisqu'en
fait en m'intéressant à Bitcoin, on
tombe sur le sujet de l'énergie
évidemment très très vite et j'ai voulu
creuser ce sujet et ce qui m'a amené à
écrire aujourd'hui sur l'énergie avec un
livre qui s'appelle l'énergie face
cachée de la monnaie.
Qu'est-ce que tu es humble ! Tu as bossé
dans les la télé, les communications, le
chiffrement, pardon, la
cryptographie, un sujet qu'on aime
énormément. On ne dit pas crypté mais
chiffré ici. Sébastien Gouspiou,
bonjour. Bonjour.
Vous pouvez vous Tu peux te présenter
sur Bien avec plaisir. Donc Sébastien
Gouspiou, je suis fondateur de
cfondateur de Big Block. Donc c'est un
groupe qui englobe plusieurs entreprises
de mining de Bitcoin à l'international
et avant
avant rien de notable. Alors aujourd'hui
on va parler tout un tas de trucs de
monnaie d'énergie de système monétaire
de stabilité de l'euro, de géopolitique
allié à tout ça. Déjà vous deux, merci
d'avoir libéré dans votre emploi du
temps un peu de temps pour notre
communauté. C'est pour ça qu'on tourne
que maintenant parce que vous aviez que
un créneau à cette heure-là. Et juste
après vous, on fait une émission sur la
Chine. Donc restez connecté. À 7h, on
parlera de Chine. Pierre Sébastien, je
voudrais avoir votre analyse sur ce qui
se passe sur l'euro, sur le dollar, sur
les sanctions, sur la stabilité
monétaire. Qu'est-ce qu'une monnaie ?
Pourquoi la monnaie en fait c'est de
l'énergie stockée ? Et qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand on quand on
imprime, quand on fait de la cavalerie ?
avec l'imprimante pour faire de l'euro
magique ou du dollar magique. Pierre,
qu'est-ce qui se passe avec l'énergie,
la monnaie et l'inflation ? Alors
effectivement, il y a ce lien entre
l'énergie et la monnaie que j'ai essayé
de développer dans le livre mais et que
bizarrement certaines personnes ont du
mal à admettre. La première chose que
j'ai pu dire, je dis bah vous faites
payer votre salaire, votre salaire c'est
votre travail, le travail c'est de
l'énergie. Donc vous avez déjà dans
votre tête établi cette équivalence
entre l'énergie et la monnaie puisque
vous acceptez la monnaie. Alors pas
comme l'énergie stockée plus comme une
représentation de l'énergie puisque
aujourd'hui ce qu'on reçoit c'est pas du
de l'or, ça a été de l'or et à ce
moment-là tu as raison, c'était c'était
de l'énergie. L'or c'est des atomes donc
c'est de l'énergie euh c'est de
l'énergie condensée he du point de vue
de la science de l'énergie. Euh là
aujourd'hui on reçoit une une monnaie
numérique donc c'est de l'information.
Euh et l'information c'est quoi ? c'est
une une réduction d'entropie. Donc ça,
l'entropie, c'est un autre concept. Il y
a deux concepts qu'il faut absolument
connaître au 21e siècle, c'est l'énergie
et l'entropie. Alors, l'énergie, tout le
monde pense connaître ce que c'est que
l'énergie. En fait, c'est un concept qui
est encore évolutif aujourd'hui et qui a
qui a une histoire qui remonte en gros à
la voisine, on remonte au 18e siècle
pour commencer à définir ce que c'est
que l'énergie. Et euh aujourd'hui, on
peut dire que l'énergie en fait, c'est à
peu près tout le monde qui nous entoure.
Et même nous-même étant composé
d'atomes, on peut nous analyser
s'analyser comme euh une masse
d'énergie, une une ce qu'on appelle dans
la science de l'énergie une structure
dissipative. Donc les humains, les êtres
vivants sont des structures
dissipatives. La monnaie s'analyse comme
un système aussi dissipatif qui réduit
l'entropie de la société. Donc tout ça,
c'est des concepts que j'essaie
d'expliquer, que je peux développer mais
mais en tout cas ça ce lien entre
énergie et monnaie est absolument
crucial à comprendre. On va continuer un
petit peu après à parler d'inflation,
pas politique monétaire. Votre avis sur
ce qui se passe dans la finance.
Sébastien,
tu peux nous parler de quoi ? Non, ben
ça ça m'intéresse. L'inflation euh le
l'évolution de le de l'économie, le la
relation à au robinet monétaire euh à à
l'impression monétaire débridé. Oui, moi
j'ai plein de choses à dire là-dessus.
Je peux déjà commencer par dire que
contrairement à ce qui nous est annoncé,
on n'est pas en croissance. La France
est en récession depuis 2022. pas
uniquement la France hein, c'est euh a
priori quasiment toute l'Union
européenne, en tout cas l'Italie,
l'Espagne, même au-delà de l'Union
européenne, l'Angleterre annonce des
chiffres de croissance alors qu'on est
on est en récession évidente. Euh je
peux t'expliquer le mécanisme si tu le
souhaites. Tu as peut-être pas compris
la dialectique du politique. Nous sommes
en croissance négative.
Oui, mais non, là on a vu le nouveau
ministre de l'économie venir et annoncer
au premier trimestre une croissance de
0,6 %. En l'occurrence, c'est faux. On
est on est encore en récession depuis
2022 et si tu veux très grave parce
qu'une récession parce qu'on va être en
récession toute l'année 2025 également,
une récession consécutive de 4 ans tu as
jamais connu ça depuis 1929. Donc on est
en train de vivre à mon sens euh un
écroulement sans précédent et je pense
que c'est un écroulement de cette
monnaie fiat qui est l'euro qui est le
premier euh qui est la première de ces
monéfiates en terme de fragilité parce
qu'elle ne porte même pas euh la
souveraineté euh nationale. Donc c'est
ce qui la fragilise encore plus que les
autres monnaies avec lesquelles on a
abusé de de la planche habillée. Donc
même pas de souveraineté nationale. En
plus on n pas d'énergie plus que ça par
rapport aux autres. Quand on voit
comment les Chinois produisent de
l'énergie ou les Américains produisent
de l'énergie et quand on voit la taille
de l'armée américaine ou la taille de
l'armée chinoise, on se demande si
l'euro n'est pas une monnaie fantôme qui
est bquée, qui est soutenue que par du
blabla, du mensonge. On va pas dire du
mensonge, mais on va dire des lunettes
roses sur les perspectives économiques.
Pierre, qu'est-ce que tu ressens quand
tu entends un politique parler de
monnaie ? Et après on je veux qu'on
parle de quand un politique parle de
Bitcoin ou quand un journaliste parle de
Bitcoin. Pierre, alors quand il parle de
monnaie, on voit on entend souvent le
mot confiance qui vient parce
qu'effectivement ces monnaies l'eurou le
dollar mais c'est encore plus vrai pour
l'euro parce que comme tu le soullignes,
il y a pas l'armée américaine pour
soutenir le dollar qui qui est une sorte
de monnaie d'échange avec les les
monarchies du golf pour les protéger
leur leur business du pétrole. l'euro
n'a même pas ça. Donc effectivement,
c'est uniquement euh la confiance. En
fait, il y a pas de confiance. Il nous
mente en parlant de confiance parce
qu'il y a une obligation de l'utiliser.
À partir du moment où tu es obligé
d'utiliser un truc, on on te demande pas
si tu as confiance ou pas, tu es juste
obligé de l'utiliser. Donc déjà, il y a
un premier problème, c'est quand on nous
parle de confiance de la dans la
monnaie, en fait ce qu' ne veulent ce
qu'ils appellent confiance, moi
j'appelle ça monopole. En fait, c'est un
monopole. Donc aujourd'hui, il y a pas
de débat. Euh donc la confiance est
forcée, l'utilisation est forcée et
c'est le premier problème de l'euro,
c'est ce que l'euro a plein de
problèmes, notamment l'inflation de la
masse monétaire. Ça c'est une évidence
pour tout le monde quand on voit le
pouvoir d'achat qui qui s'effondre. Mais
surtout il y a il y a il y a cette voilà
cette incapacité à finalement à à
représenter une souveraineté et surtout
un accepter un pluraliste. Quelque chose
qui marche bien, ça doit résister à la
concurrence. Et que tu me décris un
petit peu, ça ressemble à une mafia.
Genre tu utilises ça, je te protège ou
c'est notre monopole. Petite précaution
alatoire, cette vidéo n'a pas de
caractère à vous conseiller en
investissement où je passe les détails.
Donc c'est juste on vous écoute. Ça n'a
aucun caractère financier ou de conseil
et vous ne payez pas. Et d'ailleurs,
n'hésitez pas à nous soutenir sur Tipi,
on a besoin de vous, la communauté pour
pouvoir vous faire plein de vidéos
encore. Pierre, je te relance avant de
passer la la parole à
Sébastien. Quand on voit la confiance,
les mots, les mots, la confiance dans
l'avenir, les mots, les mots, les mots,
on dit toujours que la confiance se
construit goutte à goutte et se
perd-telle une hémorragie ? Qu'est-ce
qui se passe quand on perd la confiance
sur une monnaie ? C'est effectivement ça
peut aller très vite. Ça peut aller très
vite. Il a fameux phénomène des bankrun
qu'on a qu'on évoque
souvent. Il y a plein de gardes de fou
évidemment sur la possibilité d'un
bankrun. À partir du moment où il y a un
monopole, c'est vrai que les gens sont
un peu coincés. Bitcoin notamment est
une porte de sortie et on a bien entendu
Christine Lagarde et la BCE parler de
Bitcoin comme une porte de sortie qu'il
faut fermer hein puisqueeffectivement
cette porte de sortie qui est maintenant
ouverte dans le monde entier ça leur
fait très peur. D'où le Pourquoi ça leur
fait peur ? Bah parce que s'il y a s'il
y a cette porte de sortie, c'est qu'il y
a cette forme de concurrence euh des
facto qui se déjuré. Enfin, au point de
vue du droit, il y a ce monopole de
droit, mais dans les fêtes, le monopole
n'existe plus. Depuis 2008, depuis
l'invention de Bitcoin, on peut dire que
n'importe quelle société humaine peut
utiliser Bitcoin dans le monde. Donc dès
lors, un un monopole monétaire, il est
maintenu par le droit. Euh et c'est ce
qui ce qu'on observe en France et en
Europe. Tu es obligé non seulement on
est obligé de l'utiliser, mais en plus
il y a toutes sortes de barrières qui
sont mises placées fiscal comptable et
cetera pour t'empêcher d'utiliser une
autre monnaie. Euh je note au passage
par exemple les fameuses monnaies
complémentaires locales. He les
monnaaies locales c'était la un peu le
folklore pour amuser la galerie. Ils ont
ils ont mis dans le code monétaire et
financier que ça peut pas dépasser
quelques milliers d'utilisateurs. Donc
donc oui, il peut y avoir une une
concurrence mais évidemment il faut
qu'elle soit toute petite et
négligeable. Et avec Bitcoin évidemment
c'est tout à fait différent puisque là
pour Bitcoin c'est une monnaie mondiale
qui a montré sa fiabilité, sa sécurité
et ça ça ça les gêne énormément. D'où le
torrent de propagande qui est déversé
sur les acteurs du secteur comme
Sébastien et moi et
surtout vers les les épargnants pour
c'est surtout le mensonge par omission
d'ailleurs parce que en fait euh ils
évitent de parler de Bitcoin parce que
du coup ça légitimerait quelque part
Bitcoin s'ils en parlent c'est que ça
existe. Si ça existe, faut que je m'y
intéresse. ils évent d'en parler et puis
et on est bombardé donc de messages
comme quoi voilà il faut mettre de
l'argent sur son plan départ et cetera,
des choses qui sur son sur son assurance
vie voilà des trucs qui si vous avez
enfin si ceux qui nous écoutent ont une
assurance vie je les invite à comparer
la performance de leur assurance vie par
rapport à Bitcoin par exemple sachant
que c'est des horizons de temps on parle
de plusieurs années hein dans le cas on
a ça veut dire qu'on a une épargne qu'on
veut garder dans sur plusieurs années et
là les statistiques sont absolument
impitoyables Et évidemment, le passé
n'est pas prédictif du futur, mais il y
a des tendances quand même. Ne pas
comprendre son passé, c'est être
condamné à le revivre, non ? Voilà, il y
a tout à fait, tout à fait. Et en plus,
il y a des métriques de réseau puisqu'on
parle dans le cas de Bitcoin, on parle
d'un réseau qui soutend la valeur des
Bitcoin évidemment parce que les Bitcoin
sont juste des droits d'usage de ce
réseau en fait. Technique
technologiquement, c'est des droits
d'usage d'un réseau et ce réseau se
développe à grande vitesse. Donc, il y a
aucune raison que ça s'arrête. En tout
cas, à court terme, on peut dire que
pour les 5 à 10 prochaines années,
Bitcoin a a des grosses perspectives de
de croissance en terme d'adoption.
Je te laisse terminer. Non, c'est
c'était l'essentiel de ce donc on va
passer la parole à à Seb et avant, je
répète encore que cette vidéo n'a aucun
caractère de conseil financier ou quoi
que ce soit. Sébastien, quel est le type
de propagande ? Quel est le type de fake
news que tu peux entendre dans la bouche
des gens qui sont
patentés journalistes, patentés
politique ? Qu'est-ce que tu entends
comme
blabla et de propagande contre Bitcoin
selon toi ? C'est c'est toujours les
mêmes. On a à peu près toujours les
mêmes sujets là. On en a de nouveaux qui
arrivent de plus en plus là récemment.
Enfin, en tout cas, on note que les
journalistes disent qu'on est des cibles
idéales pour pour le Rquê International,
hein, parce que euh donc on a des
monnaies qui sont facilitatrices de
trafic, de blanchiment d'argent et que
nous-même on est euh on est limite dans
cet écosystème de de des des grands
mafieux, hein. Donc ça c'est ce qu'on ce
qu'il y a de pire parce que c'est un
mensonge et monté. Il y a rien de plus
enfin il y a rien de plus hasardeux que
de vouloir séquestrer quelqu'un pour
réclamer une rançon cryptomonnaie. Il y
a quand même toutes les chance de de se
faire serrer au moment de la de la
première transaction. H et voilà, ça
c'est le premier truc qu'on entend,
qu'on entend souvent, même là après les
événements récents qu'il y a eu, on
entend encore des des chroniqueurs, des
spécialistes en tout qui viennent sur
les plateaux pour expliquer ça.
Ça en d'autres périodes, ça nous amuse.
Là, maintenant, on trouve que d'abord
ils nous mettent en danger et puis et
puis surtout bah ils conchit
complètement leur déontologie de base
qui consiste à pas raconter de fake news
à la télé. Et bon là, c'est ce qu'ils
font quand ils disent que le Bitcoin est
une monnaie idéale pour le blanchiment
d'argent. Voilà, sur la blockchain
toutes les transactions sont notées.
Alors, tu penses que c'est la première
des Il y en a plein d'autres, hein. Euh
deux trois autres. Oh bah le l'autre
c'est évidemment le la catastrophe
écologique hein, le fait que
ça consomme beaucoup d'électricité, on
entend beaucoup. et dans une dans une
époque où une électricité est précieuse
et qu'il faut pas la gaspiller. Un petit
troisème
euh que te dire le Bitcoin faire pousser
les cheveux. Non non, ça on l'entend
jamais. On entend rarement des choses
positives. Enfin, tout dépend de d'où on
écoute hein. Mais non, vraiment le le
premier c'est le c'est l'histoire de
l'écologie, de l'électricité qui dénote
une incompréhension totale de ce qu'est
l'énergie, l'électricité, de ce qu'est
un réseau électrique. Voilà. Quand on
entend des des gens comme Jean-Marc
Daniel venir à la télé et dire "Mais il
y a pas d'électricité pour les mineurs,
on a plus d'électricité." Voilà. Et que
maintenant on réalise que ça y est,
c'est de notoriété publique, que notre
nucléaire travaille pas assez. Donc on a
on en a beaucoup sous la [__] on
pourrait produire beaucoup plus
d'électricité.
On va on va revenir sur le côté
énergétique avec Pierre. Juste une
seconde. Moi, je vais te poser une
question toute simple. Bon, je connais
déjà la réponse mais j'ai envie de
t'entendre me la formuler. Pourquoi le
Bitcoin qui est parti de zéro est
maintenant à plus de 100000 balles ?
C'est une fuite par rapport à la monnaie
? C'est de l'opportunisme ? Qu'est-ce
que c'est
? C'est Ah bah c'est le c'est les deux.
Oui, il y a une fuite de C'est ce que
disait Pierre à l'instant. C'est un plan
B le Bitcoin. Donc c'est un plan de
sortie h qui permet à des gens qui ont
identifié qu'on va dans le mur au niveau
monétaire de de se protéger et qui
permet à des gens qui ont pas compris
qu'on allait dans le mur monétaire grâce
à Bitcoin à la découverte de ce que
c'est qu'une bonne monnaie de réaliser à
quel point on est en danger. Donc euh
voilà. Selon toi, nous sommes en danger.
Euh si tu veux. Oui, mais enfin la
démonstration que on est en on est en
décroissance en en récession depuis 4
ans. Je peux le faire de manière tout à
fait universitaire. Je peux le prouver,
le démontrer, c'est très facile. Oui,
hein. Globalement, hein, quand tu quand
tu donnes le PIB réel, c'est ce qu'a
fait là donc le ministre de l'économie
quand il est venu avec ou sans la
prostitution et la drogue. Hélas avec
parce que maintenant ça fait partie du
chiffre. Donc quand on annonce ce
chiffre du PIB réel, c'est le PIB
corrigé de de l'inflation. Sauf qu'on
corrige pas bien l'inflation. que c'est
assez simple he la façon est calculé en
fonction de d'un panier. Donc tu as des
poids qui vont déterminer les dépenses
de d'un ménage par exemple 12 %
l'énergie. Et ces ratios là ont été
calculés à une époque où l'économie
était à peu près stable, il y avait pas
d'inflation. Après la crise Covid, il y
a eu il y a eu un phénomène d'inflation
assez fort qui a frappé essentiellement
les domaines de l'énergie et de
l'alimentation. Or, ces deux poids sont
toujours côtés à la même taille.
C'est-à-dire que l'énergie fait toujours
12 % euh des dépenses d'aménage alors
que c'est un secteur qui a connu une
inflation énorme. Donc on est plus à 12
%, on est à 20 %. Et donc c'est un
exemple hein, mais c'est pareil pour
l'alimentation. L'alimentation est
donnée comme poids à 3 % dans les normes
de ligne C. L'inflation a fait que ça
est passé à 4 et demi mais on corrige
pas de ça. Donc en fait on te fait
croire
que une fois qu'on a fait le calcul avec
le le déflatteur que tu es en que tu es
en croissance. Par exemple en 2023, je
crois qu'on on annonçait 5 et demi de
croissance. C'était la Banque de France
qui annonçait ça. Non c'est l'INC hein.
C'est les mais tu veux c'est partout
c'est international. On on utilise des
vieux ratios qui sont plus du tout
effectifs aujourd'hui qui donnent pas la
réalité des faits. Mais comme tout le
monde fait à peu près pareil, un
personnel est le premier à la loi pour
dire en fait tous les chiffres que je
vous donne depuis 4 ans sont
complètement binons. On est en
récession. Pierre quand entend Sébastien
développer tel un universitaire brillant
mettre les yeux en face des trous de la
réalité financière. Qu'est-ce que tu
peux m'en
dire et comment tu perçois ceux censés
nous informer que ce soi nos ministres,
nos journalistes ou nos économistes
quand tu les entends expliquer leur
réalité face à ta réalité ? Ouais. Je te
dis bah c'est tu l'as dit c'est un
écosystème en fait. Les économistes, les
journalistes, les politiques, ils ont
c'est des gens qui ont en commun de de
viser un objectif qui est leur pour ce
qui est politique leur élection. En
fait, son on élite des gens qui sont des
champions de l'élection, qui sont pas
des champions de l'action. Euh et à
partir du moment on est champion de
l'élection, ça veut dire qu'on va on va
avoir un focus sur sa réputation qui est
qui devient extrême. Et aujourd'hui, la
réputation est décorrélée des
accomplissements, c'estàdire de la
réalité puisque le numérique amplifie
euh la et déforme la réputation. On va
avoir on va donner beaucoup d'importance
à une action lui lui accorder beaucoup
de réputations liées à une action qui
dans l'ancien temps je dirais sans avant
le numérique n'aurait peut-être pas eu
le même écho. Donc on a une cette
distorsion qui est introduite et qui est
amplifiée par les les journalistes
puisque les journalistes sont une petite
partie de la de l'information
aujourd'hui he faut faut faut
relativiser le leur influence diminue
mais il y a toujours la télévision en
tant que médias qui rassemble beaucoup
de gens. Euh donc oui, jeusserai tout à
fait à ce que ce que disait Seb euh et
ben j'ajouterai que l'inflation
effectivement elle devrait être mesurée
en fonction de l'inflation de la masse
monétaire. L'histoire du panier de
consommation qui permettrait de mesurer
l'inflation, c'est une invention pour le
coup des politiques et de et de l'INC en
l'occurrence en France puisque c'est eux
qui sont qui fournissent les chiffres
aux politiques. Donc il y a une là
encore l'INC fait partie de cet
écosystème puisque ils fournissent les
chiffres qui vont bien au gouvernement.
Sachant que le gouvernement utilise ces
chiffres pour négocier les salaires des
des fonctionnaires. Donc il y a un
intérêt objectif à à truquer les
chiffres forcément à la bas à la à la
baisse. Ah, tu dis truqué, moi je dirais
en joliv. Voilà, minimiser en tout cas
le chiffre de l'inflation pour faciliter
sa négociation salariale avec les
fonctionnaires. Donc la composition du
panier serait devrait être sujette à un
débat démocratique mais qui est
impossible. La seule mesure objective,
c'est la masse monétaire. L'augmentation
de la masse monétaire. C'est ça la vraie
inflation. Pourquoi c'est pas possible
d'avoir un débat démocratique ? Al parce
que le choix du panier est totalement
arbitraire et tout le monde va avoir un
avis différent. Ça va être impossible de
de de se mettre d'accord. Et en plus
l'INC l'INC va nous expliquer qu'en fait
c'est mieux si le la composition du
panier est secrète parce que si la
composition du panier est secrète les
acteurs économique ne peuvent pas la
manipuler parce que si tu sais que voilà
il y a donc on est vraiment dans une
hypocrisie totale puisqueeffectivement
l'INC a beaucoup plus d'incitations à
truquer les chiffres que les acteurs
économiques eux-mêmes à pas les truquer
à les présenter sous le meilleur je les
enjolivés voilà je dirais même que la
règle comptable aujourd'hui a pu
paraître cohérente à un moment et donc
l'idée même pas de nous mentir siamment,
c'est de continuer à faire semblant de
croire que ces indicateurs restent
restent valable. Je suis convaincu qu'un
un Mozart de la finance comme Emmanuel
Macron sait qu'on est en récession
depuis 2022. Je pense que les ministres
de l'économie s'ils y réfléchissent un
petit peu, c'est une démarche qui est
assez facile à faire quand même de
réaliser que les chiffres sont faux et
depuis quand ils sont faux. C'est c'est
un travail qui a donc je suis convaincu
que nos dirigeants ont conscience de ça.
Alors je me fais l'avocat du diable.
Je me mets à la place de
notre Hermè Bruno Lemire par exemple. Si
on annonce à la plebe que le pays est en
faillite, que nos
finances sont à vol, les agences de
notation nous tombent sur le paltau, on
se fait dégrader et là c'est encore plus
l'avalanche, l'avalanche. Donc je
défends Bruno Lemer à mon corps
défendant. Tu tu suputes une
compréhension du phénomène de Bruno
Lemer qu'il a pas du tout. Ah, tu es
pire que moi, toi ? Bah non, euh en
l'occurrence, non. Euh, il a jamais
démontré euh dans sa dans son ministère,
il a jamais démontré une vague
compréhension de l'économie, de la
monnaie ou de quoi que ce soit. Euh et
encore aujourd'hui. Donc euh non, quand
je dis nos dirigeants, je pensais pas à
Bruno Lemer euh précisément. Ni Eric
Lombard peut-être. Éric Lombard, c'est
un second couteau, c'est ça ? Ah bah
oui, oui, totalement. Oui, si on l'a mis
là lui en tant que littéraire comme
ministre de l'économie si tu veux,
c'était évident que c'était pour avoir
les coups des franches et pas avoir un
ministre de l'économie qui se mêle
d'économie pour enfin moi, c'est
vraiment la lecture que j'en ai faite.
Donc là, on rentre directement dans le
dur par ta faute. Désolé,
désolé. Et et euh on rentre dans le dur
là. Donc là, si je vous ai bien compris,
on se retrouve avec des lunettes roses
sur la réalité de la situation. On se
retrouve avec des prospectivistes à la
ramasse incapable d'anticiper autre
chose que leur propre
astrologie. On se retrouve avec des
journalistes sous le robinet de
l'information ayant des connaissances
économiques relativement parcellaires et
transmettant une population qui est le
pied au plancher pour payer des taxes
des taxes des taxes des impôts, des
impôts, des impôts, des services publics
qui se cassent la figure, des services
publics qui se cassent la
figure. Pour vous deux, la France, elle
va où là ? parce que là vous commencez à
me faire peur.
Alors j'ai parlé récemment de
mexicanisation. Avant moi d'ailleurs
Éric Larchevc, notre confrère de Ledger
avait parlé le premier de mexicanisation
mais le terme était je trouve un peu dur
pour le Mexique qui est un très beau
pays. Les Mexi sont un peuple très
sympa.
Je trouve que on est on ressemble
peut-être plus au Liban qui est un pays
qui était autrefois prospère avec une
une voilà une homogénéité
culturelle qui qui se défendait. Il y
avait une prospérité, c'était la Suisse
du Moyen-Orient et puis la fragmentation
de la société est
arrivée. Je vais pas développer comment
parce que c'est même pas ça le problème.
Tu connais le Liban ? Je connais des
Libanais qui m'en parlent régulièrement.
Oui. Et quel secteur d'activité ils ont
sur place ? Ils se font verser leur
salaire à ilt ils sont partis. Je je
malheureusement les élites ont fuit le
Liban. Oui. Donc c'est des gens que
qu'on trouve aujourd'hui à Paris euh et
merci pour eux. Il faut ils font ils
font contribuer notre prospérité
aujourd'hui. Mais ça c'est c'est tout à
fait révélateur. En tout cas
l'incapacité de faire le parallèle entre
la situation de la France et celle du
Liban me semble intéressante parce qu'on
en parle jamais. Donc c'est pour ça que
j'ai parlé de mexicanisation parce que
c'est plus neutre ça ça sur sur BFM ou
sur des chaînes comme ça ça passe mieux.
Mais je pense qu'à un moment il va
falloir parler du Liman et qui est
encore une fois en plus un pays plutôt
francophone et cetera. Donc c'est il y a
beaucoup de de parallèles à tirer.
Certes plus petit mais la taille du
pays, on nous avance toujours que la
France est pas pareil parce que c'est
plus grand hein. C'est pareil pour la
Suisse. La Suisse qui est aussi un
système politique extrêmement
intéressant parce que décentralisé on
nous on nous rétorque toujours que ça
marche en Suisse parce que c'est plus
petit. Non, je je vois pas le rapport en
fait. On peut très bien avoir le même
système politique que les Suisses et
aujourd'hui euh je crois qu'en terme de
PIB par habitant euh voilà c'est ils
sont deux fois deux fois au-udessus de
la France euh alors queon était en gros
sur les mêmes lignes dans les années 80.
Euh aujourd'hui on a été complètement
dépassé par les États-Unis et la Suisse
alors qu'on était assez assez proche
dans les années 80. Donc on est on est
parti en vrance c'est toujours avec
style mais on est parti en vri depuis
les années 80 sur le plan politique et
économique et là effectivement il faut
il faut se reconnecter au réel hein.
C'est ce c'est c'est en gros ça la
différence entre la gauche et la droite
c'est la connexion réelle. Ils ont pas
pas les mêmes hein les suivant qu'on est
à gauche ou à droite. Il y en a qui sont
plus dans une approche euh idéologique.
Donc les idées vont triompher sur le
réel et au besoin on va devoir maquiller
le réel pour montrer que les idées
gagnent. Et puis le la la droite qui est
plutôt connectée au réel et qui se fiche
un peu des idées euh enfin qui est moins
focalisé là-dessus. Euh mais cette
dialectique euh c'était bien dans un
pays
prospère où où ça marche où les choses
marchaient. euh ce que les Américains
appellent social trust, hein, c'est le
euh il y a il y a fait confiance
sociale, c'est voilà, la confiance
sociale euh c'est c'est comme ça qu'ils
expliquent leur prospérité en fait
depuis euh depuis leur fondation. Euh
alors Fati dit que c'est la démocratie
mais en fait je pense que la démocratie
c'est juste une manière d'établir le
social trust. Le truc vraiment crucial
c'est le social trust. quel que soit le
système politique. Alors quand on est un
petit pays, c'est plus facile
effectivement d'avoir du social trust
parce que tu connais on connaît tout le
monde en gros quand c'est un grand pays,
c'est le système politique effectivement
joue un rôle crucial. Donc certains
disent comme ifati
donc que
que d'origine libanaise justement il
connaît bien la question du Liban et il
explique que la démocratie il a mesuré
empiriquement que la démocratie est un
facteur de surperformance des des des
actions et des des investissements. Ils
l'ont mesuré empiriquement ils en ont
fait dans dans société je dirais
quasiment un produit. Donc en tant
qu'expert financier, il a intégré ça.
Mais moi en tant que plutôt dans une
approche plutôt économiste, je dirais
c'est c'est le social trust qui est la
confiance sociale qui qui fait la
prospérité et on est en train de la
perdre à cause de la fragmentation de la
société. Donc après ça se manifeste à
tous les niveaux euh effectivement
notamment évidemment la sécurité euh
mais pas que hein. C'est c'est aussi euh
les perspectives économiques qui sont
entamées. Seben d'autant plus que tu le
disais les gens
euh voilà ils sont à fond pour essayer
de payer leurs charges, leurs taxes et
tout ça. Nour leur gamin, les emmener à
l'école sans se faire emmerder, éviter
de se prendre des coups de couteau. Bien
sûr.
que ce que tu les points de quand tu
quand tu poses la question de savoir où
on va, oui, la réponse ne peut être que
super inquiétante. Mais ce que je veux
dire, c'est que dès lors que tu fausses
les indicateurs, si tu veux, tu mens sur
la valeur de ta monnaie. C'est hyper
grave en fait parce que les contrats ne
suivent pas, les salaires ne suivent
pas. Pour ça que les gens aujourd'hui,
ils voient l'inflation, ils voient leur
panier de
nourriture exploser à la hausse, mais
ils voient pas leur salaires grossir.
Pourquoi les salaires grossissent ?
parce qu'on le on n'accepte pas
l'inflation telle qu'elle existe. On
veut pas la déclarer et on dit qu'on est
en croissance, tu veux. Donc ton
instinct te m pas. Tu vois bien que tu
es pas en croissance. Et donc il y a
cette dicotomie entre l'économie perçue,
c'estàdire quelque chose qui va pas du
tout pour le citoyen et puis ces
politiques qui viennent à la télé pour
nous dire que tout va bien. C'est très
grave, ça va pas bien du tout. Quand on
est en récession depuis 4 ans, c'est
qu'on est dans un système économique en
train de s'écrouler et donc les gens le
ressentent. Donc pour répondre à ta
question, moi je ne vois qu'une
explosion une explosion sociale. Je vois
pas comment il pourrait en être
autrement. Tant qu'on corrigera pas ça,
qu'on a'ura pas un discours honnête sur
l'état de notre économie parce que c'est
très grave. Tu vois en fait quand on
entend Beirou ce matin ou hier là dire
j'ai demandé à tous les Français de
faire un effort mais on leur ment sur le
constat. Il faut si on veut demander aux
gens de participer, il faut être honnête
avec eux et donc leur donner un constat
tel qu'il est tel qu'il existe. Et si on
fait le constat tel qu'il existe, il est
extrêmement inquiétant. C'est sûr qu'on
devrait tous se retrousser les manches,
tous avoir un élan patriotique et se
dire là on va dans le mur, il faut qu'on
se réveille. Mais c'est dès lors qu'on
ment sur les indicateur, qu'on m sur la
situation réelle du pays, on peut pas
euh avoir l'adhésion du peuple pour le
sortir de cette ornière. Est-ce que
Pierre ou ou c'est est-ce que vous avez
essayé de vous mettre à leur place ?
Est-ce que vous avez essayé de de
comprendre pourquoi ils prennent le
contrôle de la dialectique ? Pourquoi
ils ont les relais de contrôle de
dialectique ? Est-ce que est-ce que vous
êtes pas dit ou s'ils en sont réduits à
nous flutter à ce niveau-là, c'est que
la situation est complètement instable
et que s'ils disent la vérité, ça va
faire comme en thermodynamique, quand il
y a de l'instabilité en thermodynamique,
ça pète. Et comme il ils vivent sur la
bête ou ils ont des plans de carrière
sur la bête depuis 30 40 ans, ils se
disent ou là là là, historiquement
parlant, à chaque fois qu'il y a eu ce
type d'instabilité, on on est obligé
d'apprendre à courir le 100 m en 9
secondes parce que les fourches vont
très vite et peut-être en prenant le
côté avocat du diable, ils essayent de
gagner du temps parce que ils appliquent
la stratégie de l'ours. la stratégie de
l'ours qui est on est tous autour du feu
et il y a un gros ours qui arrive.
L'objectif c'est pas de courir plus vite
que l'ours, c'est de courir plus vite
que le dernier clampin. Et s'il faut
faire des crocheptes aux autres pays, à
notre petits copains pour éviter de se
faire mordre en premier, il est en train
de se passer ça. Donc là, ils essayent
peut-être de faire des petits
crocheppates à d'autres pays. Je crois
même pas qu'on en soit à une compétition
internationale, tu vois. Je vois même
pas ça comme ça. Au-delà de la
géopolitique, au-delà de notre niaiserie
totale en terme d'anticipation, de de
prospective, tout ce que tu constates
depuis des années que tu fais cette
émission, tu reçois des gens brillants
qui voi très bien ce qu'il faudrait
faire et on voit l'État et nos
gouvernements successifs ne pas du tout
aller dans cette directionl.
Tout ce que je vois aujourd'hui moi,
c'est que tous ces gens qui participent
de de ce roman national, de ce narratif,
ce que disait Pierre, les économistes,
les journalistes, les banquiers, tout
ça, c'est un panier de crap qui lui se
sort de euh de cette de cette GAVJI
parce que la création monétaire, c'est
une véritable GAVJI, hein. Et tu
constates ça quand tu vois que les
fonctionnaires de l'Union européenne de
l'Union européenne s'augmentent sep fois
dans l'année quand les gens rament comme
des fou chasseux. Eux, ils ont bien
compris que
euh lesffet enfin on on a vraiment trop
trop de création monétaire. L'inflation
ne ne compense enfin ne l'augmentation
des salaires ne ne compense pas du tout
l'inflation. Bah eux, ils s'augmentent
sep fois ou six fois dans l'année. C'est
comme ça on compense le truc et on se
sort complètement de la problématique du
petit peuple.
Oui, c'est c'est exactement ça. C'estàd
que quand Merou dit faire des efforts,
mais faire des efforts pourquoi ? pour
faire perdurer le système dont il
profite
effectivement et perdurer faire perdurer
le système en fait c'est assister à
l'aggravation des problèmes qu'il qu'il
génère ce système. Donc effectivement
faire des efforts mais il y a aucune
vision politique. Et peut-être qu' il
leur manque cette grille d'analyse que
je propose dans mon livre sur les sur
l'énergie. C'est-à-dire que qu'est-ce
qui rend les gens heureux ? Alors bah il
y a plein de théories là-dessus. Il y a
plein de philosophies qui vont expliquer
qu'est-ce qui rend les gens heureux.
Personnellement, je m'intéresse aux
philosophiees orientales, notamment au
taoïme, qui euh elle mérite de de poser
un regard juste sur la nature en fait.
Qui est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on est ?
Et donc ça ça je l'ai expliqué dans le
livre en disant on est de l'énergie.
Comment ça s'appelle ton livre déjà ?
L'énergie face cachée de la monnaie.
Alors la monnaie joue, c'est un des une
des quatre parties du livre. La monnaie,
l'économie c'est une des quatre parties.
Les trois autres, on parle d'énergie,
d'entropie pour définir ce que sont ces
concepts relativement abstraits pour la
plupart des gens. Donc, j'essaie de les
préciser et je parle aussi de société et
je parle aussi de religion et de
croyance. Euh alors, pourquoi c'est lié
tous ces sujets ? Parce que ce qui rend
les gens heureux en fait, c'est la ce
qu'on appelle la réduction d'entropie du
point de vue thermodynamique.
C'est-à-dire réduire l'entropie, c'est
quoi ? C'est réduire son incertitude par
rapport à l'avenir. D'accord ?
Essentiellement, l'entropie du point de
vue scientifique, c'est de l'information
cachée. Donc, par définition, l'avenir,
on le décrit avec une information qui
est cachée puisqu'on l'a pas
aujourd'hui. Donc, c'est ça l'entropie.
Donc réduire l'entropie, c'est très
important parce que si on n pas ce flux
de réduction d'entropie, c'est là où on
devient malheureux. On se sent mal à
l'aise. L'exemple des éoliennes est
intéressant. On a on a un paysage qui
depuis des millions d'années n' pas
changé. Les paysages au large de la
Baule ou ou d'ailleurs des côtes
françaises. C'est des paysages qui
avaient jamais changé depuis très très
longtemps. En tout cas sur la mer, sur
la terre, il y avait des constructions
mais sur la mer, ça bougeait pas. Puis
là, tout d'un coup, on voit des
éoliennes offshore. Donc là, du coup,
l'avenir devient incertain. Même le
paysage, même quelque chose d'ussi
permanent qu'un paysage que j'observe
depuis ma fenêtre, il peut être changé
par quelqu'un qui est qui est loin, que
je connais pas, qui a décidé pour moi.
Donc ça, c'est l'entropie. Cette
personnel, elle a augmenté notre
entropie, c'està-dire qu'elle a augmenté
notre incertitude par rapport à
l'avenir. Parce que ce qu'on dit, si on
peut changer un paysage comme ça,
qu'est-ce que quoi d'autre on peut
changer dans l'avenir ? Pour moi, hein ?
C'est donc c'est ça qui rend les gens
malheureux. Donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut pas faut pas valider les les
projets d'éoliennes en mer et surtout
quand on voit ce que ça rapporte au
niveau énergétique, on pourrait en
parler après. Mais globalement le ce qui
ce qui va rendre les gens heureux c'est
ça. Et pourquoi ça ? parce que encore
une fois notre nature profonde c'est
d'être des structures thermodynamiques,
ce qu'on appelle une structure
dissipative en langage scientifique.
Donc ça veut dire que on a un flux
d'énergie qui rentre, l'alimentation
essentiellement et on produit du travail
avec cette énergie chimique qu'on
transforme. L'énergie, on la transforme,
on la consomme pas. Quand j'entends
consommation d'énergie, ça me fait
toujours bon dire on utilise de
l'énergie, on la transforme, on ne la
consomme pas, elle ne se perd pas.
L'énergie est incrée. Elle est elle est
si elle elle a pas été créée, ça veut
dire qu'elle a toujours existé. Fais-moi
un petit coup de la voisier là. Alors la
voisier, c'est ça, c'est bah rien ne se
perd, rien ne se crée, tout se
transforme. Alors à l'époque où il a
énoncé ce principe, c'était en au 18e
siècle et ben c'était la la masse en
fait. On parlait plutôt de la
conservation de la masse dans une
réaction chimique. Et puis au fil du
temps on s'est aperçu qu'en fait c'était
beaucoup plus général que ça. C'était
l'énergie qui se conservait de cette
façon. Donc elle est incréée. Ce qu'on
appelle incréée, c'est que personne l'a
jamais créé. l'énergie elle existait
elle existe donc depuis toujours. C'est
qu'il y a pas d'origine du temps. Il y a
pas il y a pas un instant zéro puisque
s'il y avait un instant zéro, c'estàd
qu'à cet instant là, on aurait créé de
l'énergie. Donc et c'est intéressant
parce que cette première loi qui
s'appelle le principe de conservation,
c'est une des très rares théories
scientifiques qui est que aucun
scientifique ne conteste plus
aujourd'hui. Elle est très ancienne, on
monte au 18e siècle. Tout le monde a
essayé de la démonter, même avec la
physique quantique et cetera. Et
aujourd'hui encore en 2025 tout le monde
est d'accord sur ce principe. Donc c'est
ça c'est un principe qui a des donc des
ramifications philosophiques importantes
notamment il y a pas de création donc il
y a pas de créateur et cetera et cetera.
Euh le deuxième principe c'est la la
flèche du temps. Donc c'està dire que
l'entropie a tendance à augmenter. Donc
l'entropie comme je disais on veut
plutôt qu' la réduire. Donc et pour la
réduire le deuxième principe nous dit il
faut fournir de l'énergie. Donc il faut
un flux d'énergie pour pour c'est c'est
le principe du frigidaire. faut bien le
brancher le frigidaire sur la prise.
Donc ça c'est Et le troisème principe
qui est le plus intéressant et qui est
le plus récent aussi dans son sa
formulation, c'est celui qui nous
intéresse parce que c'est la il parle de
structure dissipative, c'est-à-dire de
nous et là il dit une structure
dissipative, ça a tendance à maximiser
le flux d'énergie qu'elle capture et
pour ça elle s'auto-organise. Donc c'est
un principe d'autoorganisation et de
maximisation. Et pour s'auto-organiser,
on utilise de l'information, c'estàdire
une diminution d'entropie. Donc en fait,
chaque fois qu'on utilise qu'on acquère
de la connaissance, en fait, c'est pour
s'auto-organiser. D'accord ? Donc on va
s'auto-organiser, ça veut dire j'acqu la
connaissance par exemple pour construire
un meuble, bah du coup, je vais dépenser
moins d'énergie pour construire ce
meuble. D'accord ? Globalement, c'est ça
le principe. Je reçois des données GPS,
c'est de l'information. Globalement, je
vais dépenser moins d'énergie pour me
déplacer et cetera et cetera. Je gagne
un concours d'éloquence. Et comme ça, je
j'utilise moins d'énergie pour fluter
tout le
monde. Alors là, c'est c'est un exemple
un peu moins un peu moins facile à
appréhender, mais j'essaie de rester sur
des trucs assez basiques qui parlent à
tout le monde. Donc sur le GPS par
exemple, ça marche assez bien. Tu reçois
de l'information et du coup tu
économises de l'énergie. Donc
l'information correspond bien à une
économie d'énergie. C'est le principe de
la monnaie. La monnaie est une
information qui économise de l'énergie.
Pourquoi ? parce que ça va permettre à
deux personnes de s'échanger des biens
qui avec le troc par exemple sans la
monnaie aurait été très compliqué, la
transaction aurait pris beaucoup
d'énergie pour se réaliser et il y
aurait eu moins de transaction donc on
aurait pas maximisé le flux d'énergie
qui qui nous traverse nous traverse au
travers des transactions et au travers
de l'alimentation qu'on prend et cetera.
Donc voilà un peu ce qui ce qu'il faut
connaître pour un politique pour faire
de la politique. Si on veut rendre les
gens heureux, il faut partir de ça parce
que si on sait pas si on n pas intégré
ça, effectivement on va être dans une
approche idéologique. Euh sculter de
l'air chaud, brasser de la fumée. C'est
ça. On va brasser de C'est dramatique.
C'est le smoke and mirrors comme disent
les anglais. La politique. Smoke and
mirror c'était la fumée et les et les
miroirs pour l'illusion. Et
effectivement la politique
malheureusement aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que c'est beaucoup manipulé
des illusions.
C'est d'une gravité d'une tristesse.
Qu'est-ce que c'est la dette pour toi
Pierre ? Alors la dette c'est
intéressant parce que c'est une promesse
d'énergie future. C'estd que quelqu'un a
dit je vais fournir mon travail pour les
20 prochaines années pour rendre
l'énergie qu'on m'a la monnaie donc la
représentation de l'énergie qu'on m'a
donné, je vais la la rendre avec mon
travail sur les donc je promets de
l'énergie. Donc une dette, c'est une
promesse d'énergie et euh contrairement
à la preuve d'énergie dans Bitcoin, donc
on voit déjà le rapport l'opposition
presque y et yang entre Bitcoin et et la
les monnaies fiates créées par la dette.
Euh donc effectivement la dette c'est
une promesse et la promesse, la
différence entre la promesse et la
preuve, c'est que la preuve ça va
satisfaire celui qui cherche la vérité,
donc plutôt le scientifique que je suis
qui va pouvoir vérifier une preuve. Euh
la promesse, là on est dans le domaine
de la croyance, dans la croyance que la
promesse va être tenue.
Confiance,
confiance et croyance, on voit bien
qu'il y a déjà une une petite
différence. Et dans le cas d'une dette
obligatoire, il y a il y a pas cette
confiance. On t'impose une dette, la
dette publique, on te l'impose, hein,
c'est en plus de l'impôt, enfin, on peut
en parler, mais la dette quand quand les
DAT fait de la dette, en fait, il
colleent des impôts supplémentaires sans
te sans que tu sois d'accord
nécessairement. Donc ouais, c'est la
dette. Voilà ce que c'est. Il faut bien
que les gens comprennent ça, que c'est
une promesse de d'énergie que eux ont
fourni. Et ça aussi, c'est une grosse
différence avec Bitcoin, avec les
mineurs Bitcoin comme Sébastien, c'est
que quand Sébastien il mine du Bitcoin,
c'est lui qui paye l'énergie et il
récupère en vendant en vendant ses
bitcoin à son fournisseur pour payer la
facture du fournisseur. Donc il
réinjecte la son gain dans l'économie
réelle avec en payant le fournisseur
d'électricité. Dans le cas de la de la
dette, c'est pas ça. Dans le cas de la
dette, le banquier il monétise notre
énergie future. C'est pas la sienne.
Donc déjà quand on a compris ça, on voit
bien que il y a une grosse différence
entre la création monétaire Bitcoin et
la création monétaire euro et qu'il y a
peut-être une forme de d'arnaque
effectivement dans dans les les fameux
intérêts qu'on nous colle quand on
empreinte. Parce que des frais de
dossier, je pourrais comprendre parce
qu'il y a des systèmes informatiques
pour gérer ça, des frais de dossiers,
admettons, mais des des taux d'intérêt
sur de la dette, sur quelque chose qui
est donc prise, on a enregistré que vous
allez rembourser et cetera.
Ça pose ça pose des problèmes qui
d'ailleurs sont contestés pas que par
moi. Il y a même la finance islamique
qui interdit ce gen toutes les religions
les religions en général les trois
monothéismes a priori sont contre les
parce que je pense qu'on n'est pas les
premiers à à souligner les dangers
effectivement de monétiser l'énergie
future des gens parce que tu parles de
religion et tu parles de l'usure. Moi,
je vais te parler de géopolitique et de
peuple et je te dis la meilleure façon
pour mettre un peuple en laisse, c'est
de lui mettre de la dette sur la tête
comme ça tu peux lui tendre la dette, tu
peux lui tendre sa lisse. Est-ce que la
dette c'est une façon de contrôler les
peuples ? Est-ce que les religieux
avaient déjà compris ça ? Tu parles de
finances islamiques, alors tu parles du
dinar or, du dinar du diram argent et tu
parles de l'impossibilité de faire de
l'usure. Pour toi, la dette c'est quoi ?
Ah ben moi, tu le premier terme qui
m'est venu à l'idée quand tu as posé la
question à Pierre, c'estes esclavage.
Euh donc oui, pour moi créer de la
dette, c'est créer des conditions de
l'esclavage futur des
populations. Euh ouais, c'est c'est une
évidence. J'avais fait une émission de
radio euh je crois que ça s'appelle NAN
TV sur un un média local. C'est ceux qui
coupent les pilones électriques. Non,
c'est pas eux. Euh non. Euh non, c'est
un média local euh tout ce qu'il y a de
plus euh normal. Sain et serein. Çain.
Ouais. Ouais.
Et c'était à l'époque du début du
Coville là et donc à l'époque du quoi
qu'il en coûte et donc j'expliquais bien
que fallait pas rêver le quoi qu'il en
coûte aujourd'hui on allait le payer et
que les gens allaient le payer qui
allaient le payer d'abord les plus
pauvres parce qu'on allait d'abord taper
sur les minimas sociaux gratter sur le
chômage sur le RSA sur sur tous les
acquis sociaux en fait et c'est
exactement ce à quoi on est en train
d'assister. Il y a pas de magie. Euh dès
lors qu'il a dit euh le quoi qu'il en
coûte, c'était sûr qu'on on allait euh
en chier des ronds de serviett derrière
pour rembourser cette dette-là qui est
complètement délirante quoi. Délirante.
Me me dis pas du vocabulaire comme ça
avec euh Big Brother YouTube qui essaie
désespérément de nous dééférencer par
tous les moyens avant les la campagne de
présidentielle même pour des histoires
de rond serviette. Même pour des
histoires de rond de serviette et
surtout pour des histoires de rond de
serviett parce que qu'est-ce qu'on est
en train d'en prendre plein la tête.
Je reviens je reviens sur le stockage de
l'énergie, la preuve de stockage, la la
référence. Alors, au départ, c'était
l'or parce que l'or pour faire ça d'une
façon triviale, il fallait prendre sa
pelle, sa pioche, aller creuser des
trous, ça prenait du temps, la substance
était difficile à aller chercher et puis
il fallait le raffiner puis il fallait
ensuite le purifier, le mettre en petit
lingot. Donc c'était du temps de
travail, donc de l'énergie stockée dans
un truc rare qu'on pouvait pas euh
inventer sous le pied d'un cheval ou
part de Garci mort et compagnie faire
d'un tour de magie multiplier les petits
pains en or. Là la
dette cette énergie future. Est-ce que
tu t'es amusé à convertir la dette
française en baril de pétrole et en
consommation annuelle de baril de
pétrole de la France ? Ça représenterait
combien d'années ? Euh alors moi j'ai
pas fait le calcul mais j'ai vu que tu
avais évoqué ce calcul là sur une de tes
émissions récentes. Non, ça fait plus de
70 ans. C'estàd que on a on a 70 ans de
pétrole de consommation annuelle de la
France au jour J 2025. C'est soit un peu
plus je demande à me faire fact
checker. C'est entre entre 70 76 ans.
Bon une
chiant, on va dire merde l'algorithme de
YouTube. Euh ouais là on va déclarer la
guerre. Partagez cette vidéo et on part
en guerre. Revenons. Revenons à notre
sujet de stockage de l'énergie. Quand tu
entends nos politiques européennes, nos
politiques
françaises avec la signature de Tata
France sur les marchés
financiers, tu vois ça comment ? On
attire encore des investissements en
France. On parie sur le futur, on parie
sur nos infrastructures, sur notre
système hospitalier, la qualité de nos
routes, nos nos nos infrastructures tout
court ou c'est simplement on est
tellement tellement à
poil qu'on est obligé de courir et
maintenir le vernis et cacher tout sous
sous le tapis. Pierre Sébastien
Pierre réagit, je l'entends sur la
dette, il y a il y a plein de choses à
dire. Effectivement, la dette française
déjà, c'est pas 3000 milliards, c'est
plutôt 5000 milliards parce que en fait
ils intègrent pas les retraites des
fonctionnaires. Donc et alors pourquoi
ce qui ce qui est amusant, c'est que les
anglo-saxons intègrent la dette des
fonctionnaires mais ils en ont beaucoup
moins. Donc mais du coup il l'intègrent
et en France on l'intègre pas parce
qu'elle est énorme et du coup 5000
milliards déjà à 3000 milliards tout le
monde sait qu'on peut pas rembourser.
5000 c'est encore plus évident. Et parce
que ils disent en gros "Ah oui mais la
retraite des fonctionnaires c'est hors
bilan parce que on peut la changer par
la loi." Donc en gros, ils disent "On
pourrait par la loi annuler leur traité
des fonctionnaires", ce qui est
évidemment absurde. Donc même dans les
normes comptables, il y a des choses
bizarres qui relèvent du la fabrication
du consentement ou même du mensonge. Euh
donc c'est la première chose qu'on peut
dire sur la dette française en tout cas.
Et il y a plein d'exemples comme si on
reprend l'exemple du Liban, ils ont
annulé leur dette très simplement. C'est
la valeur de la monnaie qui est tombée à
zéro. Ils ont répudier leur dette. Non
mais la valeur de la ils ont même pas eu
besoin. Si tuas si la valeur de l'euro
tombe à zéro, je je rembourse la dette
française avec un Bitcoin. C'est bon, on
a remboursé, on n pas fait
défaut. Et c'est un peu ce qui va se
passer en fait. C'estàd que l'Eur je
pense se passer. Oui, ce qui peut se
passer, on va dire ce qui peut se passer
ça, c'est la valeur de l'euro qui tombe
à zéro. C'est pas la valeur du Bitcoin
comme certains banquiers l'ont dit comme
ce que les anglais appellent du wishful
thinking. C'est non un un réseau qui se
qui se développe qui se construit une
infrastructure sa valeur tombe pas à
zéro. Donc la valeur du Bitcoin on peut
dire ce qu'on veut elle peut baisser
elle peut monter mais elle va pas tomber
à zéro parce que l'infrastructure elle
est là. C'est comme dire internet va
disparaître. C'est à peu près aussi
intelligent dire que la valeur de
Bitcoin va tomber à zéro. C'est à peu
près aussi intelligent que dire qu'un
internet va disparaître. puisque un
réseau pire tout pire que qui est utile
qui sert à des centaines de millions de
gens dans le monde, ça a jamais disparu
historiquement il y a aucune raison que
ça disparaisse parce que ça sert ne
serait-ce que pour les paiements donc ça
disparaîtra pas. Du coup comme le
Bitcoin est en quantité limitée é 21
million c'est 21 millions de droits
d'usage du réseau. Sans les Bitcoin, tu
peux pas utiliser le réseau. Donc c'est
le droit d'usage du réseau. Si le réseau
il est là, il est utile, ça sa valeur
tombe pas à zéro. Bon euh je prends
parfois l'image d'un pont où on
distribuerait des cartes pour utiliser
le pont. C'est des des passes pour
utiliser le pont. la valeur du pass,
elle va elle va être liée à l'usage du
pontin et le si le pont il disparaît
pas, la valeur du pass, elle disparaît
pas non plus. Donc c'est c'est ces gens
qui disent la valeur du Bitcoin va
tomber à zéro. Déjà ça ça veut dire
qu'ils ont pas compris ou ils sont en
train de mentir. Ce qui est peut-être
encore plus grave parce que comme c'est
des patrons de banque, on va dire ils
ont compris. Sinon, on a mis des abrutis
à la tête des banques. On va pas
supposer ça. Évidemment, c'est Tu
connais le principe de Peter. Oui, c'est
pour ça que je suis pas si sûr. Mais
mais par contre c'est ce qui est
certain, c'est qu'ils sont peut-être en
train de nous mentir. En tout cas, il y
a des gens autour d'eux qui sont très
intelligents et qui font en sorte queils
disent des gros mensonges comme ça. Donc
ça alimente si ça si tu veux, ça
alimente cette espèce de d'ambiance où
tu te dis de toute façon tout ce qu'ils
disent c'est des mensonges. Tu vois,
finalement quand tu as un truc aussi
évident que la valeur du Bitcoin va
tomber à zéro, tu dis ils sont en train
de s'il nousent là-dessus, ils nous
montent sur quoi d'autre quoi. C'est
c'est ça le problème. Donc donc par
contre la valeur de l'euro peut tomber à
zéro. Ça oui, puisque c'est des
promesses comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure, une promesse à partir du moment
où tu sais qu'elle sera pas tenue, elle
vaut zéro. Donc la valeur du Bitcoin,
elle peut tomber à zéro. La seule chose
qu'il maintient, c'est le monopole. Du
jour où il y a pas le monopole et c'est
on l'a dit tout à l'heure, en pratique,
le monopole a disparu. On est que sur le
droit. Donc là, on peut parler de
l'écosystème du droit. Là, il y a
beaucoup de choses à dire. On va
peut-être en parler si on parle de
sécurité, mais donc c'est il y a que ce
monopole qui maintient la valeur de
l'euro. Le jour où ce monopole
disparaît, l'euro vaut zéro. Donc la
dette vaut zéro. On est on est libre de
notre dette. C'est fini, il y a plus les
3000 milliards. Ça veut dire qu'on peut
plus emprunter. Ça veut dire qu'on peut
plus aller chercher des mé Non, ça veut
dire qu'on utilise une autre monnaie. On
utilise une autre monnaie. Faut pas
emprunter. Ou alors si on emprunte, on
crée une nouvelle monnaie. De toute
façon, l'euro c'est une création, on est
d'accord, c'est il y a rien qui qui
soutient l'euro. Il y a bien les 2500
tonnes d'or de la Banque de France qui
serait qu'ils auraient bien fait de
convertir en Bitcoin entre nous, hein,
parce que ça aurait ça aurait pris de la
valeur beaucoup plus que l'or. Donc il y
a certes 2500 tonnes d'or dans les caves
de la Banque de France, ce qui ce qui
pose un problème écologique. Tout le
monde sera d'accord he parce que là le
minage des des min des des métau rares,
c'est très très mauvais pour
l'environnement. Mais ça bizarrement on
en parle jamais de l'impact écologique
de l'or. Un petit coup de mercure. Non
mais parce que parce que les gens
croient que c'est Tu l'as dit, tu
parlais de l'or au passé, les gens
envisagent que l'extraction d'or c'est
un truc de l'ancien temps. Mais non, la
relique barbare. Oui, mais cette relique
barbare n'a jamais été aussi exploitée
et on n sort jamais autant du sol qu'en
ce moment. Exactement. Et au détriment
de l'environnement. Et ce qui est
bizarre, c'est que les écologistes de
salon sont obsédés par la l'utilisation
de l'énergie par Bitcoin et jamais ils
nous parlent d'or. C'est cette
dissymétrie qui parce que justement
double standard qui me m'interpelle
parce que justement pour eux ça n'existe
déjà plus. C'est comme tu le disais
hein, c'est une relique barbare. Donc tu
as des économistes comme Dufren par
exemple, Nicolas Dufren pour lui même
pas ils vont entendre parler de la
pollution de l'or parce que pour lui
l'or n'existe plus. Sauf que la
pollution est considérable. C'est un
lobby parce que dans la réalité si la
Banque de France a 2500 tonnes d'or et
qu'elle ne les vend pas, c'est bien pour
maintenir le cours de l'or. Et c'est
bien c'est c'est ce maintien du cours de
l'or incite des gens à faire de leur
paillage en Amazonnie par exemple. Bien
sûr. Donc elle participe de la
destruction de l'environnement en
gardant son stock d'or. Donc même ça
c'est faux. Mais de toute façon venant
du FR ça m'étonne pas puisque c'est un
lobbyiste. Je vous ai dit pas dénigre.
On ne dénigre pas.
On cite juste un lobbyiste qui qui a dit
des choses. Non mais on le cite c'est
votre point de vue qui n'engage que
vous. Je ne connais pas cette personne
et et si je vais la défendre parce que
elle n'est pas là pour se défendre.
Exactement. Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
Si si vous êtes pas d'accord, vous êtes
pas obligé de vous invectiver comme ça.
Bon, c'est un détail. Pour revenir aux
écologistes de salon, on connaît plein
d'écologistes qui gueulent et qui
braillent et qui font des grèves de la
fin et qui se font butter, qui se font
tuer en Amazonnie, qui se font tuer
parce que il y a des orpailleurs qui les
qui les fracassent. Il y a même des
gendarmes qui s'en prennent plein la
tête parce que on se fait pied euh notre
petit coin de paradis en
Amazonnie. Revenons à nos
moutons. Leur paillage, certes, c'est
compliqué. Là, on voit que l'Ouanda a
potentiellement je ne sais pas combien
de millions de milliers de tonnes dans
son sous-sol. Ça peut-être représente un
problème parce que ça va faire des gros
trous partout. Le Bitcoin, pourquoi on
dit que c'est mauvais pour l'écologie ?
Parce qu'on aime bien dire des
carabistouilles. Qui c'est ? Qui c'est ?
Parce que on va revenir à monsieur
Dufren que nous citions. Il le dit, il
le dit. Donc vous avez une dent contre
ce monsieur-là. Non mais il est il a
l'oreille des députés, c'est un des
fonctionnaires de l'Assemblée nationale
donc payé avec nos impôts et comme un
certain nombre de fonctionnaires, on va
pas généraliser, il fait du militantisme
pour sa son opinion mais ça me gênerait
pas s'il y avait une neutralité. Je peux
te couper bien sûr. Je connais pas cette
personne mais est-ce que vous avez été
vous avez essayé d'être bienveillant en
essayant de le prendre
? On a tout essayé. il a été accueilli
par l'écosystème dans des dans des
podcasts justement il a pu s'exprimer au
début et donc voilà, c'est un opposant
définitif à Bitcoin, il veut pas
l'entendre et et donc lui il a écrit la
monnaie écologique. Donc en fait lui il
a il a une proposition autre que Bitcoin
et donc il est convaincu que c'est sa
monnaie écologique qui qui va gagner.
Bon bref, il mérite même pas cette
parenthèse. Mais si tu veux, il dirige
un singang qui a quand même la capacité
à écrire des rapports. Euh je crois non
euh Rousseau. Rousseau Institut
Rousseau. Et donc il ils te vendent des
rapports clés en main à l'Assemblée
nationale qui achètent ça et qui dit "Ah
le Bitcoin c'est pas bien, ça consomme
de l'énergie.
À la place de faire ça, on devrait faire
de l'hydrogène vert. Tu vois ce genre
d'absurdité quoi. Mais pour toi, c'est
une absurdité. Mais peut-être pas mais
c'est une absurdité. Enfin aujourd'hui
pour toi, c'est une absurdité. Non,
c'est pas c'est pas pour moi que c'est
une absurdité. Techniquement, bah tu
vois une utilisation de l'hydrogène vert
en France, on a donné 9 milliards de
subventions à l'hydrogène vert. 9
milliards en France. En France hein, je
parle pas de ce qu'a donné l'Union
européenne pour cette espèce de délire
technocratique qui consisterait d'un
seul coup à ce que tout fonctionne à
l'hydrogène. Bruno Lemire, il est rentré
d'une réunion sur l'hydrogène vert à
Oslo. Il est revenu en disant
l'hydrogène va remplacer l'électricité.
Voilà. Donc le propos de l'hydrogène
vert, c'est d'utiliser de l'électricité
verte pour faire de l'hydrogène he par
par électroly nucléaire par exemple de
l'électricité non carbonée. Si tu veux,
l'idée est pas mal parce que euh le
l'électrolyseur, il est en capacité de
s'effacer. Les nouveaux électrolyseurs
qui sortent maintenant pour faire de
l'hydrogène vert, ils sont en capacité
comme le mining de couper à la demande
de l'électricien. Mais la problématique
c'est on ne sait pas quoi faire de ce
qu'il produit cet élect cet
électrolyseur. Et donc même si tu donnes
gratuitement l'électricité, si EDF donne
l'électricité gratuitement aux
électrolyseurs, il faut 25 ans pour les
rentabiliser. Or, ils ont 15 ans de
durée de vie. On donne 9 milliards à
cette dabee.
Je discutais. Non non mais c'est une
dupe totale et en plus ça a été porté
par les gaziers qui ont fait croire au
gouvernement et à l'État qu'on allait
pouvoir réutiliser leur réseau gaziier
qui était en dé enfin qui sont plus
amortissables aujourd'hui qui qui ne
rapportent plus d'argent parce que la la
diminution du volume du réseau gazier a
beaucoup baissé. Donc aujourd'hui tu as
plus rien qui justifie l'entretien de ce
réseau gazier. Les gaziers disent les
gaziers c'est NG et compagnie on va
pouvoir mettre de l'hydrogène vert dans
nos dans nos tuyaux. On a déjà tout le
réseau hein et donc on arrive à lever 9
milliards de subventions d'état avec une
idée toute pétée comme ça. Parce que si
tu mets l'hydrogène dans le dans l'acier
du gaz, évidemment c'est corrosif. C'est
corrosif, ça tient pas. Donc ils ont
fait des essais pour prouver que c'était
intéressant de lever de l'argent pour le
pour l'hydrogène vert en injectant 20 %
d'hydrogène dans le gaz naturel que tu
as dans les tuyaux. Et là ils disent ça
marche mais comment tu resépares les 20
% d'hydrogène du gaz naturel arrivé au
bout ? Tu peux rien en faire. En plus,
tu as aucun appareil ménager qui
fonctionne à l'hydrogène vert. Tu peux
pas faire du frigo ou quoi que ce soit
avec. Ça donne un peu l'impression que
c'est une énorme arnaque si tu veux.
C'est un truc de dingue. C'est une
énorme arnaque. Pour toi, c'est une
arnaque. Ah oui oui, c'est une énorme
arnaque. Ça donne un peu l'impression
que tu comprends pourquoi je mets les
précautions oratoires ? parce que je
vois chacun a son point de vue et il
faut beaucoup de temps pour le démontrer
son point de vue. C'est pour ça qu'on
fait des grandes émissions longues et
harde où on rentre dans le détail et je
vous dis à chaque fois ça sert à rien de
vous invectiver à gauche et à droite.
Essayez de se mettre tout le monde
autour de la table. Essayons de se
mettre tout le monde autour de la table
parce que la France est en train de
sombrer Oui. Et que et que on a plus le
temps, on a plus le temps de s'envoyer
des piques. On est bien d'accord. Mais
autour de la table, tu n'as que des gens
qui soutiennent l'hydrogène vert. Ça
fait quand même maintenant 4 ans qu'on
sait que attends, on a voté 9 milliards,
on a donné que 2 milliards. Il y a 7
milliards à économiser. Tu vois, ils
sont au budget. Donc si tu les retires
du budget, dans seul coup, on a 7
milliards en plus. Euh, il faut arrêter
le le massacre, ça ne sert à rien et ça
marchera jamais. On a on sait pas le
vendre. Il y a pas de demande. On est en
train de créer une offre à coup de
milliard alors que tu n'as aucune
demande en
face. Donc, c'est très grave si tu veux.
C'est c'est l'argent public, c'est notre
argent, c'est l'argent de tes impôts,
hein. Donc il faut arrêter ce genre de
délire. Tu remarqueras que depuis 2 ans,
les gaziers ne vont plus au charbon à
propos de l'hydrogène vert. C'est fini.
Démerdez-vous avec ça. Et voilà, tout le
monde a touché ses subventions, a fait
ses petits ses petits ces petites
explorations dans son coin et on est on
est au niveau zéro. Il y a rien qui
s'est passé. Pierre. Ouais. Dans ce que
tu soulèves, la question que tu soulèves
est très intéressante parce en fait ça
pose la question du de la démocratie
sensitaire. C'est je m'explique en fait
effectivement le le Bitcoin c'est un
logiciel libre ça coûte rien. Il y a pas
de lobby derrière contrairement à ce que
certains essayent de faire croire. Il y
a quelques entrepreneurs comme Sébastien
et moi qui prennent leur après-midi. On
a le plaisir d'être avec toi cet
après-midi pour en parler mais
franchement je sais pas je connais pas
de lobbyist Bitcoin. Il y a que des
entrepreneurs qui prennent sur leur
temps libre pour faire essayer
d'expliquer un peu ce que ce que c'est.
Et en face effectivement, il y a des des
lobbyes, on va appeler ça comme ça, très
puissants. Il y a le lobby effectivement
de la monnaie Fiat, rien que ça. Donc
c'est don la personne que nous avons
cité fait partie des facto parce que son
tout ce qui dit corbor c'est en gros les
éléments de langage et banque central.
Donc effectivement, langage que toi.
Oui, mais c'est je peux faire quasiment
un verbime si tu veux entre ce qu'il dit
et les éléments de langage de la banque
centrale. Donc ça ça pose effectivement
la la question de d'un débat
démocratique équilibré sur les questions
par exemple d'énergie et de monnaie
puisque c'est le sujet qui m'intéresse
personnellement, qui nous intéresse
tous, qui nous intéresse bien sûr et qui
intéresse tout le monde, tous ceux qui
nous écoutent. Donc c'est vrai que
d'avoir un débat démocratique débarrassé
de tout conflit d'intérêt sur ces
questions est compliqué. même nous on
nous accuse d'avoir un intérêt dans
Bitcoin, ce qui est partiellement vrai
parce que franchement euh enfin voilà,
c'est c'est une mécanique qui nous
dépasse largement. Nos efforts sont
dérisoires par rapport à la la dynamique
qui porte Bitcoin aujourd'hui. Il y a
des États qui ont adopté. Oui, c'est ça.
Donc nous, on essaie juste de dire aux
français passez pas à côté quoi. En
gros, vous êtes passé à côté d'internet,
vous avez laissé les gars femmes
dominer. Ne laissez pas à nouveau
d'autres des puissances étrangères et
d'autres dominer. Bitcoin qui est un
réseau de même genre que le web paire à
paire donc sans serveur central euh
essayer de essayer de d'avoir une
politique industrielle du numérique. Bah
au lieu de ça, on a des on a des
secrétaires d'état au numérique qui
succèdent qui invitent le patron de
Microsoft, invite notre concurrent
chinois enfin travaill chez Microsoft
après leur ministère immédiatement
derrière voilà vont faire des start-ups
en touchant au passage des gros
financements. Donc on a vraiment une une
absence de vision et de politique
industrielle sur le numérique qui est
qui est qui est qui est en
total opposition avec l'importance que
prend le numérique aujourd'hui. Ça
devrait être la priorité. Les années ma
jeunesse en tant qu'ingénieur c'était
France Télécom, c'était le passage de la
voix sur IP, la transformation de France
Télécom, le TGV, c'était ce genre de
chos aujourd'hui c'est wanadou.
Ouais, mais bon, les gars femmes, ils
sont américains, ils sont pas parce que
pour les mêmes raisons, il y a eu le
rapport, bon, tu te souviens peut-être,
tu es trop jeune, mais tu te souviens
peut-être du rapporterie qui expliquait
qu'il n'y aurait pas d'application
commerciale sur internet parce que donc
aujourd'hui, on a à peu près entendu les
mêmes choses sur Bitcoin. Nous, en tant
que depuis que depuis que je suis sur
Bitcoin, on nous explique que non, ça ne
peut pas remplacer l'euro qui est une
monnaie tellement parfaite que elle peut
pas être remplacée par un système
décentralisé. Donc c'est vrai qu'on il y
a une dissymétrie de moyens qui est qui
est qui est flagrante. J'ouvre une
parenthèse dans la parenthèse pour
revenir à sur l'aspect politique et
l'aspect trajectoire industrielle de
plan de cap. La transition Bitcoin la
transition pardon le le la transaction
Bitcoin ça coûte un peu d'énergie ou pas
du tout ? Alors une transaction Bitcoin
c'est un message sur un réseau. Donc
c'est comme envoyer un email c'est un
message signé qui dit Alice pay Bob tant
de Bitcoin. C'est ça une transaction
Bitcoin. Donc dire qu'une envoyer un
message sur internet ça consomme
beaucoup d'énergie, qu' faut arrêter, ça
me paraît un peu suspect parce que je
pense que l'email au contraire certes
consomme de l'énergie mais économise
beaucoup d'énergie en déplacement. Avant
que je sache, on envoyait une enveloppe
avec un timbre, je pense que ça
consommait plus quand même qu'un email.
Donc je je comprends pas bien cette ce
genre d'attaque et l'utilisation de
l'énergie en Bitcoin n'est pas n'est pas
liée en fait à l'opération du réseau.
L'opération du réseau, on pourrait la
comparer à Facebook, à TikTok, à plein
d'autres trucs en nous disant "Mais non,
TikTok ça sert à rien. D'ailleurs, je le
regarde pas parce qu'en gros, on a des
gens qui nous disent Bitcoin ça sert à
rien parce que je l'utilise pas." C'est
un peu TikTok, ça sert peut-être à la
Chine pour faire d'autres trucs mais
c'est voilà, ça sert sûrement à des
gens. Moi je j'utilise pas TikTok mais
je vais jamais me permettre de dire que
ça sert à rien. S'il y a des centaines
de millions
d'utilisateurs, j'ai pas le la
prétention et l'arrogance de dire aux
gens ça sert à rien. Et pourtant sur
Bitcoin, on a des gens comme la personne
qu'on a pas cité qu'on va surtout pas
reciter qui nous disait que ça servait à
rien. Ce qui est presque insultant.
C'est je trouve ça insultant pour ceux
qui l'utilisent. Et en plus il nous
disait qu'on était des c'était un pzi
enfin c'était des accusations même de de
malversation. Donc tu vois entre ne pas
dénigrer quelqu'un mais quelqu'un qui
t'a auparavant insulté, méprisé et
éventuellement même accusé de participer
à un ponzi, ce qui est une accusation
quasiment diffamatoire. Ça ça va plus
loin. Moi, il m'a carrément accusé
d'avoir déclenché les émeutes au
Kazakhstan qui on fait 200 morts. On a
eu des accusations. Je veux juste dire
que si on parle de cette personne, c'est
parce que il fait partie de ces gens qui
se permettent de mettre des cibles sur
nous quelque part. Il y en a d'autres,
je pourrais en citer plein d'autres qui
apparent. Non mais je je vais pas le
faire parce qu'on est chez toi mais mais
franchement il y en a beaucoup qui
n'hésitent pas à mettre une cible sur
les gens qui font pas qui pensent pas
comme eux quoi en gros et ça c'est c'est
très regrettable. On connait bien le
principe et on grnait bien le problème
ici aussi parce que comme on essaie
d'écouter tout le monde forcément on
n'est pas d'accord avec tout le monde.
Les gens pensent qu'on est à gauche, à
droite, au centre, chez Pierre, chez
Sergeille, chez Michael, ainsi de suite.
Alors non, par contre quand on va
commencer à montrer les muscles, ils
vont moins faire les mal. On reparlera
de sécurité un peu plus tard. Je veux
revenir. Il y a pas des blockchains qui
consomment moins d'électricité que le
Bitcoin là-dedans ? Ah si, alors là,
faut pas nous lancer. Mais oui, bien
sûr. Il y a des gens continue ici pour
pousser un cadit. Non mais
non mais c'est c'est évident que des
gens quand ils ont vu Bitcoin, ils sont
dit tiens on va faire on va inventer
l'eau chaude, on va cette quantité
d'électricité utilisée par Bitcoin on va
la mettre à zéro et on va voir ce que ça
fait. Ah bah ça marche en fait. Et bien
sûr que ça marche. Ça s'appelle un
réseau social. C'estàd qu'en gros là, tu
as construit Facebook et euh tu as tu as
la même sécurité que sur Facebook. C'est
tout le monde est sur le même réseau.
Donc on se dit bah si j'envois de
l'argent sur Facebook euh c'était Libra
hein, c'est le principe de de la leur
projet euh cryptomonnaie. Il y a pas de
sécurité liée à l'énergie. C'est-à-dire
qu' s'ils se font hacker, euh si
quelqu'un c'est un serveur central, donc
ils peuvent se faire hacker par les
Coréens du Nord, ce jour-là, ils te
mettent le bazar dans la base de données
et puis ça y est, ton truc, il est
voilà. Donc sur Bitcoin, ça peut pas se
faire à cause de quoi ? À cause de
l'énergie. C'est-àdire que les Coréens
du Nord, s'ils attaquent Bitcoin, bah il
faut qu'ils mettent du du de il faut
qu'ils achètent tous les circuits
disponibles sur le marché. Enfin, ça va
se voir comme le nez au milieu de la
figure. Évidemment qu'il y aura un hard
fork pour invalider leur euh leur fork.
Donc sur Bitcoin, on est tranquille
là-dessus et donc certains ont dit on va
mettre à zéro l'énergie, donc on
consomme moins. Donc argument marketing,
on est vert, on consomme pas des on
utilise pas d'énergie. Bah sauf que
c'est un réseau social à ce moment-là,
c'est Etheréum. C'est un réseau social
en fait. C'est un réseau social de
développeurs et d'utilisateurs qui se
qui s'aiment bien. Ils font des
conférences de temps en temps. Il y a un
Z l'équivalent de Zuckerberg qui
s'appelle dans le cas d'Etherum Vitalic
Boutrin qui est une figure voilà
emblématique. Donc c'est c'est
respectable. Moi j'ai rien contre mais
je dis juste c'est pas la même chose que
Bitcoin parce que du coup c'est pas
décentralisé. C'est exactement comme si
vous utilisez la monnaie Facebook. Vous
êtes à la mercie de voilà
de du pouvoir central qui qui contrôle
cette monnaie. Et et c'est pire, je
dirais que c'est pire que la monnaie
Fiat parce que dans la monnaie Fiat, il
y a une contrepartie énergétique qui est
la promesse de remboursement, la dette,
la fameuse dette. Il y a quand même une
contrepartie énergétique. Dans le cas de
ces monnaies là, il y a même pas ça. Il
y a aucune promesse de qui que ce soit.
Donc ça ça en fait des monnaies quand
même un peu fragiles, il me semble. Et
j'ai pas de on donne pas de conseil
financier ici, mais j'invite les gens
qui investissent dans ces dans ces
monnaies. Personne. Voilà, je les invite
à travailler le sujet avant de se avant
d'investir en tout cas.
Je te vois bouillir. Pierre dit toujours
qu'il faut apprendre Bitcoin et non pas
acheter Bitcoin hein. Voilà. Donc on
s'est retrouvé des fois sur scène où je
disais aux chambres mais si acheté
Bitcoin et lui il faisait le nom de la
tête. Non apprenez Bitcoin. Donc il a un
message beaucoup plus pédagogique que le
mien. Parce que j'en reviens à
l'histoire de d'autres blockchain et
tout ça. Faut revenir au à la source de
de ta question première. la transaction
en Bitcoin parce que tu entends souvent
dire qu'une transaction en Bitcoin ça
consomme autant qu'un ménage américain
pendant 3 semaines et des trucs comme
ça. Donc c'est une mesure qui est pas du
tout pertinente. Pierre l'a
expliqué. Aujourd'hui on a une
consommation qui est de l'ordre de 125
terwh du réseau Bitcoin par an. Si
demain on double les transactions, ça va
rien changer à la consommation globale
du réseau. C'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre. 125 TW, ça représente
combien de centrales nucléaires à
l'année ?
Euh ça représente un paquet. Pour donner
un ordre d'idée. La France a produit en
2023 EDF, je veux dire hein pas la
France EDF a produit 400 430 TWh. Si je
peux me permettre, on peut répondre
différemment à ta question en disant
attends est-ce que est-ce que tu permets
Sébastien ? Ou non bien sûr parce que
c'est je tiens la donnée de Sébastien
donc mais c'est juste qu'il il répond à
ta question. Je voulais juste la la
reprendre différemment en disant euh en
fait ça représente la l'utilisation de
Bitcoin, ça représente euh l'équivalent
en ordre de grandeur des surplus
d'électricité du nucléaire français.
C'estàd qu'en gros l'univers
l'électricité qui est perdue aujourd'hui
parce que non utilisé en France
aujourd'hui suffirait à alimenter tout
le réseau Bitcoin aujourd'hui. Donc les
gens qui vous disent par exemple ça
consomme autant que la ça utilise autant
que la Belgique en fait non c'est 0 % de
la Belgique parce que le surplu français
par définition il est pas utilisé ni par
les belges ni par les français. Donc en
fait onxorte pas notre surplus. Mais
bien sûr que non parce que si c'est du
surplus, c'est queil il y a pas
d'acheteur. Voilà, il est on peut pas on
peut pas le faire parvenir à un
acheteur. En fait, c'est ça le problème
d'un surplus. C'est c'est que c'est que
une marchandise que tu as sur les bras
ou un flux en l'occurrence c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué un flux parce
que tu peux pas stocker le flux mais tu
peux pas le transférer à un acheteur.
Donc soit il y a pas d'acheteur, soit il
y a pas de de de moyen de la cheminer.
C'est ça un surplus d'énergie. Qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait quand il y a un surplu ?
Alors, ça c'est vraiment important parce
que les gens pensent que quand on envoie
de l'électricité à l'étranger, c'est du
surplu qu'on bazarde même parfois on
paye pour ça hein, c'est les fameux prix
négatifs. Dès lors qu'on a un client,
même si même si c'est nous qui le payons
pour l'acheter, c'est pas un surplu. Le
surplus, c'est ce qu'on enfin ce que
nous on entend comme surplu hein. Je dis
pas que la définition est exacte. J'ai
vu l'autre jour l'État camerounais a
communiqué sur desw oisifs. Eux, ils
parlent d'électricité oisf. C'estàd
qu'une électricité qui est disponible,
qu'on pourrait produire mais qu'on ne
produit pas. C'est ce qui se passe sur
le nucléaire français où tu as en
moyenne un parc nucléaire qui tourne à
60 %, peut-être 70 % dans les meilleures
années. Alors que la norme normale pour
un parc nucléaire comme celui qu'on a en
France, cette technologie
europessurisée, c'est 90 % 95 %. Donc
c'est c'est ce différentiel là qui fait
ce surplus. On il y a largement de quoi
faire travailler tout le mining mondial
sur ce surplus. Très largement rien
qu'en France. Mais si tu prends 5 % des
des surplus hydroélectriques mondiaux,
tu as un réseau quand même.
En terme de robustesse, robustesse par
rapport, je vais prendre trois cas.
Robustesse en cas de d'éruption solaire.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe si tous les
réseaux
se Mais en fait, j'avais pas fini de
répondre parce que il y a d'autres il y
a d'autres blockchain plus économiques,
enfin qui consomment pas d'électricité
hein. C'est la spécialité de tous ceux
qui disent Bitcoin consomme trop, on
peut vous en faire. On peut vous faire
quelque chose qui consomme rien du tout.
Euh mais c'est une réponse et une
problématique qui existe pas. En fait,
il y a pas de problème avec la
consommation de Bitcoin. Bitcoin se sert
sur des surplus. Donc je l'explique
toujours mais je te vois au cher la tête
mais on estime la consommation de
Bitcoin supérieure à la consommation
d'un pays comme la
Suède. C'est ce que nous disent en
général les opposants même hein. Ça
consomme quand j'ai commencé moi c'était
la Tchéquie puis la Norvège puis on est
arrivé à la Suède. Je beau pays. Voilà.
Sauf qu'on n pas créé une seule centrale
électrique pour alimenter ce nouveau
pays qui est le Bitcoin. C'est quand
même super louche non ? Qui on a privé
d'électricité ? Ça devrait mettre la
puce à l'oreille de ceux qui écoutent.
Qui on a privé d'électricité pour
alimenter cet énorme bouffeur d'énergie
qui est le Bitcoin ? Bah personne hein.
Pourquoi ? parce que c'est sur ce
différentiel entre une capacité de
production, une réelle absorption
d'électricité que le Bitcoin vient se
fixer. Et l'outil mondial aujourd'hui
permet de produire trois fois et demi
l'électricité que le monde consomme.
Pour ceux qui nous écoutent, c'est en
fait c'est cette notion de surplus
effectivement est un peu difficile à
admettre parce que les gens ont du mal à
admettre qu'il y a autant de surplus. En
gros, un/ers quasiment de la production
d'électricité, c'est du surplu parce
qu'en fait tu es obligé de dimensionner
ton usine, ton usine si tu veux pour
produire au pic. Quand c'est le pic,
c'est en gros le soir quand quand tout
le monde rentre chez soi et allume tous
ses appareils, en gros c'est le salle le
soir, bah il faut que le système suiv
mais ça veut dire que le reste de la
journée il est en le truc est en
surcapacité mais largement très très
largement parce qu'en fait l'après-midi,
il consomme rien. Donc ça veut dire que
l'après-midi tu as la même capacité de
production. C'est de l'alurolique, c'est
du nucléaire, c'est des trucs que tu
éteins pas si tu veux facilement. En
tout cas le nucléaire ça s'éteint mais
c'est compliqué. Donc en gros tuas pas
trop. Ouais, c'est ça. Donc tu as un
flux et ce flux la plupart du temps en
fait tu l'utilises pas. C'est ça la
production d'électricité. Et les gens
ont du mal à admettre ça parce qu'ils se
disent "Ah ouais mais le soir il y a des
blackout ça le métro s'arrête par
exemple parce qu'il oui au pic ça pose
problème donc il y a bien un moment dans
la journée où ça pose problème. Mais le
reste du temps les les électriciens
enfin les producteurs d'électricité
jonglent avec la demande ce que les
Américains appellent demande response.
Ils essayent d'équilibrer leur réseau
pour que ça crame pas les équipements
parce que si tu es en surtension tout
tout ton réseau est cramé. Tu peux
cramer des équipements en tout cas et et
puis au pic il faut répondre. Donc c'est
compliqué et Bitcoin a l'avantage de
pouvoir s'allumer et s'éteindre quand on
veut. Donc c'est utile aux électriciens
s'ils sont pas ils ont pas une approche
idéologique de la monnaie comme en
France où apparemment ils ont
semble-t-il une approche idéologique
parce que ils refusent de voir cette
réalité. Il y a peut-être une confusion
avec les mineurs qui tirent pour aller
chercher du Bitcoin sur les réseaux non
? Oui. Alors justement c'est ce que je
te dis là on veut répondre avec une
blockchain qui consomme pas une
problématique qui existe pas. Euh les
les mineurs encore une fois euh ils
donnent ils prennent l'électricité que
l'électricien va bien leur vendre. Donc
il ils sont pas rentables de toute façon
s'ils payent l'électricité au prix fort,
c'estàd au moment du pic, ils sont
rentables que quand ils apprennent dans
un creux et quand ils apprennent dans un
creux, ils ont un deal avec
l'électricien. En fait, le métier de
Sébastien était tes confrères, c'est
c'est négocier en fait des contrats de
fourniture d'électricité au moins cher
parce que évidemment moins c'est cher,
plus tu es rentable, plus tu es
rentable, plus tu pourras investir, tu
auras des investisseurs qui vont te
donner de l'argent pour miner. Donc tout
ça c'est vraiment une une une approche
un peu euh je dirais de voilà système un
peu métier qui est difficile
effectivement à appréhender pour le
commun des mortels qui n'est pas
familier avec toutes ces questions je
dirais de de contrat d'électricité et
cetera. Donc c'est facile de leur faire
gobertoire de consommation de la Suèelle
alors que si on regarde des choses
objectivement c'est 0 % de la
consommation de la suelle. Parce que les
surplus, c'est par définition 0 % de la
consommation d'un client. Parce que s'il
y a un client, c'est plus du surplus. Et
ça c'est un message qui est assez
compliqué à faire passer. C'est c'est la
loi de Brandolini hein. C'est c'est plus
ça prend beaucoup plus de temps et
d'énergie de de démonter une fake news
que de la de la prononcer. Mais mais on
y arrive quand même au bout du bout
parce
que donc on réalise que il y a pas de
problématique d'absorption d'énergie par
le Bitcoin et non seulement ça pose pas
de problème mais ça crée énormément
d'avantages. Donc aujourd'hui les
électriciens s'emparent de cette
technologie comme d'un outil pour les
aider comme l'a dit Pierre à équilibrer
leur réseau. C'est le cas de d'Aircot au
Texas par exemple. Mais c'est flagrant
si tu veux. C'est vraiment un outil
indispensable aujourd'hui à Aircod. Il
faut faire comme les ruses quand il y a
trop. Il y a trop. Ils allument tous les
lampadaires de l'autoroute.
Et regarde, regarde chez nous en chez
chez nous en France, il y a eu quelques
années là euh je crois que c'était au
début du Covid d'ailleurs, on voyait des
des acrobates monter au balcon pour
éteindre les enseignes des commerces et
les gens en bas applaudissaient. Ça ça
c'est vraiment ça illustre parfaitement
ce que disait Pierre. C'estàd que les
gens ne comprennent pas l'électricité.
euh absorber de l'électricité la nuit,
les commerçants, les banques, la défense
qui illuminé et tu entends les
journalistes "Mais quelle horreur !
Faudrait commencer par éteindre ça" mais
pas du tout. Là on a Ça consomme très
peu en plus les car consomment tr Oui,
d'abord ça consomme peu et surtout ça
consomme de l'énergie nucléaire de nuit
où il y a pas de charbon qui est allumé,
il y a pas de gaz qui allumé. Moi je
vais t'arrêter tout de suite. Tu as
jamais fait d'astronomie ? Tu as jamais
fait reproduire le petit rossignol de
qui se reproduit que la nuit ? La
lumière polluante, la nuit noire. C'est
un autre sujet. C'est un autre sujet. La
pollution lumineuse, c'est un vrai sujet
mais les gens pensent qu' il sauvent la
planète pas de la pollution
lumineuse de là. Il faisit pas ça pour
la pollution lumineuse. Non, il ça pour
la gabie énergétique et tout ça. Ils
réalisent pas que si on arrêtait de
consommer la nuit pour des en gaspillant
de l'électricité, leur facture
d'électricité va augmenter d'autant.
C'est certain. On a besoin de cette
c'est une espèce de batterie économique
la consommation de nuit. Donc c'est très
important qu'il y ait de la consommation
de nuit pour faire tourner les centrales
nucléaires. Donc j'ouvre une parenthèse.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe si les réseaux
plantes comme ce qui s'est passé en
Espagne qui a un blackout que tu peux
plus connecter ton terminal que tu as
plus de connexion entre les banques au
niveau mondial ? Bah c'était c'était une
cyberattaque. C'était une c'est c'était
une cyberattaque d'après ce qu'on a pu
comprendre. Ah bah euh on a différ on a
différents sons de cloche hein. Euh on a
on a on a différents son de cloches
comme quoi les Espagnols ils étaient en
train de faire des test et que la
fréquence ils voulaient passer euh au
journal de venteur en disant nous on est
100 % renouvelable mais en terme de
fréquence ça a perturbé le réseau. Ta
source de cyber attaque c'est qui ? J'ai
entendu
ça sur internet mais longtemps il m'a
dit c'est récent. Ah bon ? Ouais. Et ça
vi d'où ? Parce que je t'ai prévenu pas
de bruit de couloir de truc pas car.
Non, tu as raison, il faut éviter. Donc
comme je peux pas citer ma source, je
retire ce que j'ai dit. Bon, tu fais
bien. Revenons à ma question. On coupa
au montage. Il y a pas de montage.
Tempire tempête solaire. Alors, on a
appris grâce à monsieur Merlin que c'est
les infrastructures qui sont nord-sud
qui sont beaucoup plus sensibles à ce
type de perturbation. Qu'est-ce qui se
passe avec Bitcoin si en gros il y a un
blackout ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe quand
tu as plus de cash dans ta popoche
pourir aller chercher ton bidon de lait
? Euh, qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Alors,
il faut que tu dimensionnes le Blackout.
Alors, je te le fais à l'échelle de la
Corise, puis ensuite je te le fais à
l'échelle de la moitié de la France.
Ouais. Puis je te le fais à l'échelle de
la France, puis je te le fais par effet
domino à toute l'Europe. Bon, parce que
le le reste de le reste tout à fait
jouable, toute l'Europe. Ouais, tout à
fait cohérent. Non, parce que la tempête
solaire peut pas toucher le monde
entier. Il faut bien comprendre ça. Il y
a toujours la moitié de la planète qui
est à l'abri de la tempête solaire. Donc
non, mais parce Oui, mais il y a des
gens qui très sérieusement en débat te
disent tempête solaire mondiale, plus
d'électricité mondiale, votre Bitcoin
marche plus. Euh oui non ça ne peut pas
exister surtout c'est comme internet
c'est enfin il y a plein d'autres trucs
qui marchent laisse terminer ça s'il te
plaît pardon donc bref tu as plus de
d'électricité en Europe après
dimensionner ton blackout c'est dans la
durée aussi combien de temps bah je te
le fais une petite semaine. Pour le
Bitcoin ça n'a aucun aucun impact zéro
parce qu'il y a un minding qui est
mondial donc tu veux l'infrastructure
est soutenue par le reste du réseau.
Quant à toi, si tu veux continuer à
faire des transactions avec ton
téléphone, c'est possible un petit
panneau solaire, tu peux charger tous
les téléphones de tout ton quartier.
Mais j'ai plus d'antenne. Tu connais le
Liban un peu ? Non. Tu as plus d'antenne
pour l'internet, tu veux dire ? Non,
mais j'ai plus mon antenne 4G pour faire
ma transaction et la passé sur la 4G.
Non, pas ou tu fais un réseau mèche ?
Non, non, tu peux le faire avec tu peux
le faire comme tu le dis avec un réseau
mèche, je crois. Tu peux le faire avec
un réseau local total mais bon, c'est
pas dit qu'on soit prêt effectivement.
Donc ça ça peut être problématique. Ça
peut être
problématique. Je te dis par exemple he
si ta question c'est l'internet. En
Afrique on s'échange du Bitcoin sans
internet par SMS. Mais en admettant que
tous les réseaux soient morts, tous les
réseaux sont morts. Tu as plus de
banque, tu as plus de banque centrale.
Voilà. Ça a l'air de te réjouir. Non
mais je veux dire euh envisager que ce
soit le problème le Bitcoin qui pose
problème au moment où on aurait plus
d'électricité du tout dans toute
l'Europe si tu veux. C'est vraiment euh
avoir le problème par le petit ou de la
lordnette. Il y aurait une on serait en
véritable révolution. Là, tu aurais des
pillage, des massacres, la problématique
du Bitcoin qui fonctionne ou pas, ça
marche pas. Mais oui, terminé. Non, je
je pense que tu as tout dit mais on
pourrait on a la même question sur le le
l'informatique quantique qui soi-disant
peut péter le chiffrage. Ouais, mais à
ce moment-là, il y a plein d'autres
systèmes qui sont pétés. Donc c'est pas
c'est pas que Bitcoin qui est qui est
touché par voilà une ce genre de de
phénomène
exceptionnel. On peut dire ça aussi. Moi
j'ai toujours du mal à me projeter dans
ce genre de de c'est des scénarios
catastrophes. Voilà. De scénario
catastrophe s'appelle un signe noir.
Absolument. Ouais mais là un signe noir
pour le coup qui touche pas juste
Bitcoin. Voilà c'est ça qu'il faut se
rappeler c'est qu'à ce moment-là c'est
pas Bitcoin. C'est c'est cadé de nos
soucis. Juste une parenthèse toi qui est
polytechnicien. Est-ce qu'on t'a appris
à te comparer au derniers de la classe ?
Pardon ? Est-ce qu'on t'a appris à te
comparer au dernier de la classe ? Je
m'y suis j'ai parfois été les derniers
de la classe.
Bon, autre question, vous m'avez parlé
de monopole monétaire, de obligation
d'utiliser une monnaie et ainsi de
suite. Moi, je vais vous parler de ce
qui s'est passé aux États-Unis avec l'or
il y a il y a très longtemps, mais vous
devez vous en rappeler quand on a
décrété que la détention d'or, c'était
interdit, qu'il fallait ramener son or
pour soutenir le dollar et l'économie
avec la main sur le cœur et que bon
récemment, c'est en 72 ou en 77, je
demande à me faire fa checker, on a aux
États-Unis réautorisé la possession
d'or. Moi, je vais vous le
dire
directement, vous m'embêtez avec votre
Bitcoin et je vais t'interdire à la
population de te tenir du Bitcoin où je
vais leur dire vous ramenez vos Bitcoin,
je vais vous mettre 70 % d'imposition
dessus ou je vais vous interdire les
transactions dessus et si tu es pas
content, c'est
goulag. Qu'est-ce que vous faites avec
cette robustesse précaire face à un
pouvoir politique qui détient la
violence légitime ?
Moi, je suis convaincu que ça serait à
peu près aussi inefficace que
l'interdiction de la possession de l'or,
hein, qui a été un vrai coup d'épée dans
l'eau quand même, il faut le savoir,
hein. Ça n'a pas marché. Voilà, ça
marchera pas mieux. On peut bien me
demander de donner mes Bitcoin. Euh,
j'en ai pas.
Ouais, c'est ce que les Américains
appellent plausible deniability, c'est
que tu peux nier en avoir sans voilà de
manière plausible, sans qu'il soit
possible de dire "Mais non, vous en
avez." Et pour l'or, c'est un peu plus
difficile parce qu'on peut
perquisitionner ta maison. Dans le cas
de Bitcoin, on peut même pas
perquisitionner parce que tu peux avoir
un ce qu'on appelle un brain wallet. Tu
peux avoir ton ton secret dans ta tête
sous forme d'une d'une suite de mots.
Euh donc à l'extrême, si on était dans
un régime autoritaire, on aurait ce
genre de de complément de protection.
Mais mais franchement là, ça rejoint ce
qu'on disait sur la démocratie en tant
que facteur de
prospérité, ce que j'ai appelé la
confiance sociale. S'il y a un
dictateur, de toute façon, on a une
grosse augmentation d'entropie pour la
société. C'est l'incertitude augmente
tout d'un coup parce qu'effectivement il
est capable de tout. C'est la la Corée
du Nord, c'est à ce moment-là on a une
grosse les les citoyens ont plus le
sentiment de de de maîtriser leur avenir
et ils sont du coup très malheureux du
point de vue thermodynamique. Donc je
pense que cette situation effectivement
est un peu extrême et que Bitcoin est
presque mieux c'est mieux que l'or dans
ce cas-là parce que effectivement c'est
plus difficile à trouver. Objectivement
c'est plus facile à cacher que qu'un
lingot d'or. Bon c'est ce qu'on peut
dire. Il y a un précédent historique, il
faut savoir que la Chine a interdit
Bitcoin je ne sais combien de fois et
bon le Bitcoin est très échangé en Chine
encore aujourd'hui. Il y a un gros gros
business qui est fait notamment autour
des AIC, des fabricants de d'Asic qui
sont les seules machines de mining. Il y
a trois fabricants, ils sont en Chine.
Donc il y a un vrai gros business qui se
fait en Bitcoin en Chine avec un état
qui a été très très réfractaire, opposé
au développement du Bitcoin et tout ça.
Et malgré le fait que ce soit en Chine,
donc quand même dans la dicture
populaire qui a tout pouvoir, ils ont
pas réussi à arrêter Bitcoin. Ils ont
pas ils ont même jamais essayé de
contraindre les gens à donner leur
Bitcoin à l'État. Ils savent que c'est
une c'est pleine perdue. C'est se
décrédibiliser et faire la chasse au
Bitcoin. J'ouvre une petite parenthèse
encore. Nous remercions la communauté
chinoise du Bitcoin qui a aidé Julien
Assange et et on les remercie et je
rentre pas dans les détails. Revenons à
toi Pierre. Parle-moi d'énergie,
fais-moi rêver en terme de perspective
énergétique européenne. Est-ce que tu as
étudié le truc ? Est-ce que tu as étudié
les perspectives énergétiques chinoises
américaines ? On voit les Chinois faire
des réacteurs nucléaires à Gogo, faire
des
réacteurs au torium. Ils ont fait des
barrages à Gogo, l'or bleu. Ils ont fait
des panneaux solaires en veux-tu en
voilà des pleines et des pleines. Un mix
énergétique renforcé, développé avec des
projets. On voit les Américains, c'est
drill drill baby drill en for aller
chercher du chist. Ils vont aller
chercher les métaux dans les nodules
polymétalliques pour compléter leur leur
industrie
énergétique. Ils vont faire des parcs
nucléaires en veux-tu en voilà à
l'américaine. Et nous en
Europe, on se regarde et on se dit "Oh
la galinette au candré, qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait la galinette au candré
Il y a un peu de ça en fait ce qu'on
observe déjà la première chose pour ceux
qui nous écoutent c'est que l'énergie
euh et le PIB sont deux deux quantité
quasiment parfaitement corrélé. Ça c'est
le la fameuse la fameuse shift la
fameuse courbe du Shift Project qui
montre quee effectivement le PIB
fonction du flux d'énergie. Donc parce
que j'ai dit que les êtres humains
étaient des structures dissipatives mais
en fait l'espèce humaine est une
structure dissipative. C'est que c'est
fractal. Chaque chose est imbriquée dans
l'autre. C'est une miniature de de
l'étage supérieur. Donc l'être humain
effectivement est une structure
dissipative mais la socié une société
humaine est une structure dissipative et
l'ensemble des sociétés humaines,
c'estàdire l'espèce est une structure
dissipative. Du coup, on va maximiser le
flux d'énergie. C'est dans c'est dans
notre nature au sens loi physique, c'est
pas dans notre nature, au sens
philosophique. Au sens d'une loi
physique, c'est dans notre nature de
maximiser l'énergie. Donc toute
approche, je dirais par une exigence de
sobriété est en contradiction avec la
nature. Le trè le fameux 3è principe que
que je citais. On peut avoir une
approche par exemple sur les politiques
de démographiques parce que la
démographie en fait le
principal driver, on dirait en anglais,
enfin très facteur de de d'augmentation
de la l'utilisation d'énergie.
Contrairement à ce que nous disent les
les les écologistes, peut-être c'est
très difficile de contraindre
l'utilisation de l'énergie, c'est
d'enseigner aux gens d'être sobres,
surtout s'ils sont déjà sobres comme et
puis d'être heureux. Ça s'appelle la
sobriété heureuse. La sobriété heureuse
de qui n'est pas la sobriété subie.
C'est ça. Sobriété heureuse de de Pierre
Pierre je l'arbitre Daniè Panagunaché
aussi. Ah oui, d'accord. Elle a été
suivie euh mouvant des colibris, je
crois ça s'appelait aussi.
Ben disons que oui, il y a il y a
beaucoup de de d'escroqueries
intellectuelles sur ces questions. Donc
la le principal facteur de d'utilisation
d'énergie, c'est la population. Donc
puisque'en gros la moyenne d'utilisation
pour un humain, c'est 20 MWh par an sur
la planète à peu près, sachant que il y
en a qui sont à 30, d'autres à 60 et
puis d'autres à 10. Et en gros, je crois
que les les en Afrique, les gens sont à
10. Donc ça va être dur de leur
expliquer qu'il faut être sobre à eux,
ceux qui sont à 10. Ils vont plutôt
avoir envie d'aller à 20 ou 30 MWh par
an comme nous. euh que d'être sobre.
Donc du coup l'illusion qu'on pourrait
quelque part réduire la consommation
d'énergie au niveau global et c'est
c'est vraiment une illusion parce que ça
n'arrivera jamais pour cette loi à cause
de cette loi physique. Euh et ce qu'on
fait en France he ça reprend 1 % de la
population mondiale, c'est évidemment
dérisoire comme effet sur sur
l'utilisation de l'énergie. Donc une
fois qu'on a dit ça euh on peut on peut
revenir à la question de l'Europe dans
tout ça. Peux te couper. Alors bien sûr
tu tu écoute ce qui racontent les bricks
tu sais l'axe du mal les méchants euh tu
vois. Oui, les BR les Russes, les
Indiens, c'est ceux qu'il faut pas
écouter. Les Chinois, ils disent un
monde multipolaire, plus égalitaire. Et
quand tu réfléchis comme un chinois, tu
te dis bon plus égalitaire, ça veut dire
toi tu vas arrêter l'Européen qui pulle
sur notre dos qui nous ont fait
trébucher avec ta guerre de lopium. Tues
100 MW par tête de pipe, tu vas te
lescendre à 20 ou peut-être à 15 puis
nous on va monter. ce serait un peu plus
égalitaire. Tu comprends ça ? Bien sûr,
bien sûr. Cette aspiration euh en tout
cas à augmenter sa sa son utilisation
d'énergie, c'est le troisème principe.
Donc on est on est conçu comme ça. Donc
on peut pas aller contre ça. On peut
maîtriser la démographie, il me semble,
plus facilement. Parce que dire aux
gens, vous aurez au lieu d'avoir 10
enfants, vous en aurez que deux, ça me
semble plus facile leur expliquer vous
allez éteindre le frigidaire et puis
vous allez éteindre la lumière et
cetera. Ça c'est box wifi et mettre un
colon en fait. Ouais, c'est ça. Ça ça va
être compliqué. Par contre, si vous êtes
prospère, vous avez deux enfants en
bonne santé parce que les au passage, on
a amélioré les soins médicaux, donc au
lieu de perdre les enfants pour des
raisons sanitaires, vous allez les
garder. Oui, ça ça rend possible un
univers, une vision du futur où on
maîtrise la parce que là, j'ai pas parlé
de la courbe de de population de la
planète, là par contre, on est sur un
truc complètement exponentiel,
contrairement à ce que disent les les
démographes pour bah parce que on peut y
revenir, c'est le système Fiat qui
alimente ce ce discours de comme celui
de l'INC, celui des démographes. Bah,
dans le même sens, il faut qu'il y ait
des beaucoup de gens pour qu'on
endettete beaucoup de gens parce que
chaque personne de plus qui arrive,
c'est effectivement un endetté de plus.
Donc on va pouvoir lui faire des prêts,
il va pouvoir rembourser, travailler et
cetera. Donc le système Fiat a besoin de
de de d'une population qui augmente.
Sinon les taux d'intérêt et tout ça, ça
marche plus. Donc stabiliser la
population, ça semble un objectif assez
assez un compromis en tout cas assez
raisonnable par rapport aux
enjeux environnementaux. Tu sais ce que
je vais te répondre en me faisant
l'avocat du diable ? Maltus. Ouais.
Alors Maltus, il avait pas cette grille
analyse que je te cite parce que en fait
le 3è principe, on l'a découvert dans
les années 70. Donc il avait pas cette
cette grille de lecture plus
scientifique. Je dirais lui, il était
plutôt une sorte d'angoisse par rapport
aux ressources naturelles. Il avait pas
intégré la notion de progrès. Nous au
21e siècle, on a on a intégré la notion
de progrès notamment progrès médical,
c'est allongement de la durée de la vie.
Donc ça aussi, ça veut dire quoi
l'allongement de la durée de la vie ?
C'est que la population vieillit. C'est
souvent on te dit la population
vieillit, c'est grave, faut faire venir
des jeunes. Ben non, si si la population
a une espérance de vie plus longue,
mathématiquement les jeunes représentent
moins de monde dans la population. C'est
c'est juste mathématique. Donc non, la
population vieillit à cause de
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie. Et
c'est pas remettre des jeunes, c'est
comme si dire c'est nié en fait
l'allongement de la la durée de vie.
Donc non, il faut changer les modèles
économiques pour que les gens
effectivement aient une vie tenir compte
du fait qu'ils vivent plus longtemps.
C'est quoi changer les modèles
économiques ? Parce que là nous c'estàd
arrêtez de dire que il ils doivent aller
à la retraite à 60 ans alors qu'en vrai
ils peuvent peut-être pour certains, je
dis pas tous les métiers, certains
métiers peuvent aller largement au-delà
l'histoire de la retraite sénateur
ou alors le sénateur lui il peut je sais
même pas s'il a droit à la retraite de
bon point de vue pas forcé de fois deux
fois plus mais ça fait des réserves. Il
y a des réserves. Oui ils ont des
grosses réserves qui gèrent eux-mêmes.
Ils y ont droit mais elle n'est pas
légitime. En tout cas, en tout cas, il y
a il y a Maltus. Maltus quand on le
cite, c'est effectivement pour éviter
d'avoir le débat en fait. C'estd que ça
tue le débat. C'est comme dire c'est
fachaud extrême droite ou je sais pas
quoi. Maltus, ça permet d'arrêter la
discussion quand on veut pas l'avir.
Mais maltus, faut arrêter. On n'est pas
maltusien quand on dit ce que je dis. On
dit on est juste factuel en disant il y
a il y a le troisème principe. Ça c'est
un principe scientifique établi. Et puis
il y a la consommation enfin les
statistiques sur l'utilisation de
l'énergie par les humains. Et là c'est
assez parlant. Ça c'est même très
parlant, ça va jamais en diminu et je
parler de l'Europe, pardon. Alors
l'Europe je voulais parler de l'Europe
parce que c'est c'était ta question
initialement effectivement énergétique
consommation PIB et puis laette cendrée.
Alors moi je pense que ce qui me fait
espérer dans un avenir
riusion nucléaire parce qu'effectivement
tu vas avoir potentiellement à terme
quelques dizaines d'années tu vas avoir
une source d'énergie quasiment illimitée
et décarbonée. La fusion nucléaire c'est
ça. Donc énergie illimitée décarbonée,
c'est la solution à tous les problèmes
dont on parle aujourd'hui finalement.
D'accord ? Parce que pour d'autres,
c'est le début de de tous les problèmes
de demain. Sébastien, juste après, tu
rebondis avec les problèmes de demain et
t'expliqu Oui, parce que du point de vue
thermodynamique, c'est vrai que c'est
une une source d'énergie limitée
décarbonée pas cher. En plus, ce sera de
l'énergie pas cher la fusion. Euh
potentiellement, c'est l'explosion.
C'estàd qu'une structure dissipative, sa
destinée, c'est en fait d'augmenter son
flux d'énergie jusqu'à ce qu'elle
explose. D'accord ? Donc ça c'est le
c'est le big bang euh qui mène à qui qui
nous mène qui nous laisse aujourd'hui
euh à peu près 4 milliards d'années,
voilà, avant l'extinction du soleil.
Donc c'est une forme d'extinction
d'extinction brutale de la structure
dissipative ou d'explosion hein. Il y a
des une structure dissipative s'éteint
ou explose. He en gros c'est ça sa
destinée. Mais à 4 milliards d'années,
moi personnellement ça m'empêche pas de
dormir. Mais par contre essayer de
d'optimiser le c'est le temps qui qui
est qui est devant nous qui est donc
très très long 4 milliards d'années.
C'est c'est je trouve ça passionnant. Et
et donc il faudra maîtriser
effectivement cet aspect source
d'énergie limitée parce que ça pourrait
les gens pourraient tenter du coup de
dire "Ah bah du coup il y a plus besoin
de sobriété et puis du coup il y a plus
besoin de sobriété démographique non
plus.
besoin de sobriété sur le cuivre, le
sobriété sur notre utilisation de
l'énergie parce qu'on a de l'unité.
Voilà. Donc du coup effectivement aller
chercher des métau rar puisque
maintenant l'énergie coûte plus rien. On
peut aller chercher la le dernier gramme
de cuivre, le dernier gramme d'or et
cetera mais en détruisant la planète au
passage. Donc il y a un vrai danger si
tu veux par rapport à cette perspective
à la fois une opportunité et un danger.
Et là je suis pas j'ai pas la boule de
cristal. Mais c'est passionnant. Tu veux
compléter ?
Non. Ça il t'a volé. Il t'a volé là.
Oui. Oui. Bah tout pratiquement tout a
été dit. Bon, si ce n'est
qu'effectivement la chimère de la
sobriété est complètement à l'inverse du
3è principe. Et donc en Europe, on
marche sur la tête économiquement parce
qu'on on a on a juste de mauvaise bases.
Euh c'est comment on est en lutte
mondiale avec les autres pays et nous on
est en train de se tirer des des balles
dans le pied en permanence en créant de
l'éolien et du solaire. Enfin, c'est je
crois qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde a
compris que ces énergies là par exemple
hein, je parle je t'ai parlé d'hydrogène
vert tout à l'heure, on a le même genre
de gab sur le sur le solaire et
l'éolien. Je pense que tout le monde a
compris que c'était totalement inutile
dans notre parc énergétique à nous, dans
notre mix à nous en France et en Europe.
Mais on va continuer à en faire pendant
15 ans et en financer pendant 15 ans
parce qu'on a une inertie comme ça où
tout le monde le sait que c'est une
grosse connerie mais on va continuer à
le
faire. S'il continue à en faire en
Chine, pourquoi c'est une grosse
connerie ? Bah parce que si tu veux
c'est alors tu veux je t'explique, c'est
très facile
hein. En fait, ils servent de test au
monde entier et donc ils installent un
chez eux, ils vendent 10 au reste du
monde. Donc ils ont raison de le faire
chez eux même s'ils savent que c'est de
la doobe. Ils vendent leur dabe à
l'étranger. C'est dur. Mais c'est une
évidence, c'est pas efficace.
Le soleil le soleil peut servir dans des
régions très ensoleillées du
monde. Et encore on a le nucléaire, on a
développé tout estolien parce qu'on
avait condamné intellectuellement le
nucléaire. C'était fini hein. On allait
on allait l'abandonner. Je rappelle
qu'on a on a fermé les deux réacteurs de
de Fonim et c'est quand même ça a été
rythmé par tout une génération de
politique de gauche et de droite depuis
les années 90. C'est programmé comme ça.
On va arrêter le nucléaire. C'est voilà,
je pense que les ingénieurs nucléaires
chez DF, ils ont dû passer 40 ans de
leur vie à s'arracher les cheveux, dire
où est-ce qu'il nous amène quoi. Donc
maintenant, ça y est, on se réveille, on
réalise que finalement le nucléaire sait
bien, qu'il faut en refaire. Dès lors
qu'on en est là, pourquoi continuer à
faire du solaire et de l'éolien chez
nous ? Est-ce que vous avez un sujet qui
vous tient à cœur sur le Bitcoin qu'on a
pas abordé
? Il y a la il y a l'aspect euh
réduction d'entropie par un système
monétaire qui est important de
connaître, de comprendre parce que c'est
vraiment ça qui fait que euh on a besoin
d'un système monétaire efficace et on a
besoin de plusieurs systèmes pour plus
de résilience. Aujourd'hui, le monopole,
moi c'est mon mon discours sur Bitcoin,
c'est plutôt la fin du monopole. ce que
signifie Bitcoin aujourd'hui c'est la
fin du monopole dans les fêtes. Il
faudrait vraiment faire évoluer le code
monétaire et financier. C'estd aller
contre le lobby bancaire en place pour
vraiment bénéficier de cette concurrence
des modèles. Et ça c'est vraiment le le
message le plus important de Bitcoin,
c'est le monopole n'a plus de raison
d'être et à partir du moment où il a
plus de raison d'être, pourquoi il se
maintient
? réponse. Bah, il se maintient par la
désinformation et le mensonge
aujourd'hui. Ça c'est c'est une ça c'est
ta ta première lecture. Mais si si tu
prends l'hégémonie du dollar ou si tu
prends l'hégémonie de l'euro, bon l'euro
de dire qu'il est hégémonique même si
Bruno Le pense que ça va être une
monnaie de référence pour plus tard. Et
il y a pas que
lui, il y a aussi l'aspect géopolitique,
guerre
économique et l'aspect de qui détient la
monnaie du roi ou la monnaie de X ou Y
détient le pouvoir. Toi, tu débarques
avec tes pensées
philosophiques de de de philosophes
asiatiques, le cœur sur la main et tu
penses profondément à ce système pour la
beauté de échanges et avec tout cette
poésie. Mais en face, tu as des gars, il
te regardent, il commence à nous
emmerder, il est en train de provoquer
une fuite de la monnaie, il est en train
de provoquer peut-être un
bankrun, il nous ennuie. Est-ce que tu
as reçu euh ou Sébastien, est-ce que tu
as reçu des coups de fil euh de de
ministres en lui disant "Bon maintenant,
tu vas te calmer ou tu as reçu un petit
contrôle fiscal ou est-ce queils ont
essayé de te mettre ?" Alors, il y a eu
des coups de fil mais il m'étaient pas
destinés. Ils étaient destinés au
rédacteur en chef de tous les médias
pour dire "Ne l'invitez pas."
Bah, c'est le ça c'est
expérimentalement c'est
expérimentalement. J'ai eu des j'ai des
amis journalistes qui m'ont qui m'ont
parlé de conférence de rédaction où on
parlait de Bitcoin. Donc j'ai j'ai eu
des échos indirects et mais je peux pas
citer mes sources en l'occurrence. Mais
il est évident qu'un rédacteur en chef
qui a un journal subventionné par le
système Fiat euh qui a un actionnaire,
ça se trouve c'est une banque hein, je
pense au Crédit Mutuel en particulier.
Non mais non, le Crédit Mutuel ils sont
très bien. C'est le groupe CC et tu peux
parou mais ils sont actionnaires. Donc
je j'imagine facilement ce rédacteur en
chef se demander est-ce que je vais
passer ce sujet sur Bitcoin ou est-ce
que je vais en parler comme ça ? Pas un
peu trop de supputation là.
Bah factuellement, je regarde la
couverture médiatique sur Bitcoin et je
me dis il y a quand même un problème.
D'où vient le problème ? Et j'ai pas
trouvé d'autres explications.
Donc c'est l'explication la plus
positive, la tienne. Voilà. Mais elle
est elle a de votre chance d'être vraie
parce que si quelqu'un en a une autre,
je veux bien l'entendre. C'est la nôtre.
C'est la nôtre. Non non, mais il a
raison bien évidemment parce que si tu
veux devoir quasiment une unanimité
antibitcoin dans la presse alors que les
arguments qui montre à quel point tout
ce qui est développé dans la dans la
presse est
mensongé depuis des années, on a les
arguments en contre. Donc ça veut bien
dire que il y a il y a un parti prix.
Oui, il y a un parti prix économique. Je
pose la première question internet qui
me tombe sous les yeux.
Aujourd'hui, les énergies renouvables
entre parenthèses nucléaires y compris
ne remplacent pas les énergies fossiles.
Elles sont accumulées, les augmentations
d'électrification des usages, tout cela
sans jamais faire baisser le niveau des
émissions de CO2. Chaque année, on a des
records d'émission. Ne pense-t-il pas
qu'on aura transformé la Terre en gris
avant de trouver une solution ? Bah non,
justement, on parlait de la fusion. La
fusion, c'est de l'énergie décarbonée.
Donc il y a une perspective de sortie de
crise. Euh alors la question c'est
est-ce que avant que la fusion soit au
point, est-ce que les les émissions de
CO2 vont compromettre le climat de
manière catastrophique ?
Personnellement, j'ai pas de données
pour corroborer cette thèse là. Donc je
moi je suis plutôt optimiste sur cette
perspective euh grâce grâce au nucléaire
grâce au nucléaire et particulier la
fusion donc qui n'est qui est décarbonée
et qui ne produit pas de déchets. Je le
dis au passage pour ceux qui nous
écoutent c'est pas la fission comme
aujourd'hui où il y a des il y a des il
y a des déchets. Sachant que les déchets
d'aujourd'hui de la fission avec
l'énergie de la fusion pourraient être
traité notamment par laser. Enfin il y a
plusieurs technologies qui sont étudiées
sur retraitement des déchets qu'on
produit aujourd'hui. Donc les gens qui
nous disent c'est apocalyptique les
déchets, on saura pas quoi en faire. Bah
si justement avec la fusion on saura
quoi en faire et de toute façon ça vaut
mieux que les émissions de
CO2. Seb Oui, donc même avant la même
avant la la fusion he je pense
que euh le retour en grâce du nucléaire
donne beaucoup d'espoir pour une
production d'électricité plus décarbonée
et donc une planète plus propre au
global. Oui, bien sûr. Alors, je je vais
faire du diable. Euh le nucléaire
classique, c'est-à-dire avec de
l'uranium, des mimines, des Kazakstan.
Tu vas me dire qu'il y a pas assez
d'uranium. Je conis. Je vais dire, je
vais te dire, si tout le monde se nous
construit des réacteurs à gogo, tu sais,
un réacteur neuf, il faut le charger
deux fois plus par rapport au un
réacteur qui est déjà en activité quand
tu remplaces les crayons de combustible.
Là, on voit Trump à fond les ballons, on
voit l'Inde, on voit la Chine. Bon, on
voit un peu la France faire des plans
sur la comète. Vous avez étudié en fait
les disponibilités de la ressource ?
Oui, ça m'intéresse bien sûr.
Ouais, déjà c'est comme le pétrole si tu
veux hein. Moi quand j'étais gamin, on
nous disait qu'on avait 20 ans de
pétrole devant nous, sauf que j'ai 55
ans et on a toujours 20 ans de pétrole
devant nous. En fait, en réalité, on a
un bon siècle de pétrole devant nous.
Quel prix ? Faut arrêter avec ça. Faut
arrêter avec ça. Ça veut rien dire. À
quel prix ? À quel prix ? Tant que tu
auras pas une énergie concurrentielle du
pétrole, on s'en fout du prix. C'est le
prix, c'est le pétrole qui décide du
prix du monde, le prix de la vie au
global. Donc l'extraction
du enfin ça n'a aucun sens. Euh je dire
la la fracturation aujourd'hui coûte
cher, 20 ans, elle coûtera rien. C'est
des technologies qu'on aura appris à à
maîtriser. La problématique de la
fracturation, c'est plus la pollution
endémique que ça génère que le coût en
lui-même. Le coût en lui-même, il
diminuera avec le temps, bien sûr, comme
tout. Donc la projection de se dire "I
faut arrêter le nucléaire parce qu'on
aura plus d'uranium, c'est quand même un
truc de dingue ça. On a aucune idée des
volumes d'uranium qu'on a devant nous.
Et plus on va tirer sur l'uranium, plus
on va trouver des solutions pour
utiliser les déchets d'uranium pour
faire à nouveau du combustible et tout
ça. On le sait. Enfin, moi je suis pas
du tout inquiet sur la l'avenir de
l'uranium. On n pas encore beaucoup
cherché.
Pierre. Oui, je moi je crois surtout à
la fusion comme je te disais. Donc là,
il y a il y a plus de plus de notion
d'uranium et c'est la vraie solution de
long terme. Après, c'est vrai qu'on
observe que les métaux, les les minerais
rares, ils ont un le rendement de
l'extraction diminue. C'est
effectivement, faut creuser de plus en
plus profond mais on en trouve, on a
tendance à en trouver toujours un peu
plus qu'on pensait. Oui, pour ça le
pétrole, j'ai réagi comme ça parce qu'en
fait, il y a pas que le pétrole
américain, on continue à identifier
aujourd'hui des nappes de pétrole
gigantesque. C'est quoi sour, c'est quoi
tes sources ? Bah regarde sur internet
euh tous les derniers champs pétroliers
qui ont été identifiés en mer du Nord et
tout ça. Enfin, on en trouve tout le
temps et le gars tout le temps et moi si
tu veux, je travaille depuis longtemps
avec des pétroliers parce que un des
propos du mining, c'est d'éteindre les
torchères et donc d'utiliser le le gaz
délétaire qui sort des torchères en
grande partie du méthane pour le
transformer en électricité et pouvoir
faire du mining. Donc je bosse avec les
pétroliers depuis longtemps. Les gars de
terrain te disent "Non mais c'est quoi
cette légende urbaine de la fin du
pétrole et de la fin du gaz
Depuis des années, j'entends ça chez les
pétroliers, ça les fait mourir de rire
quand on leur dit que on arrive au bout
de des hydrocarbures. He il y en a à
gavé. On a de quoi exploiter encore
pendant un bon siècle. Ouis. Combien on
consomme de de baril de pêre ? Le monde
consomme de millions de barils par jour.
C'est un sacré paquet mais j'aurais pas
le chiff de dire des conneries. Je sais
que toi tu l'as tu l'as dit il y a pas
longtemps. J'ai j'ai entendu ça. Je
crois que c'était avec avec Merlin et
que tu avais évoqué ça. Ouais. Mais j'ai
pas Merlin. Merlin il J'ai pas retenu le
chiffre. parce que ça me parle pas
beaucoup. Berlin, il est extra. Mais en
tout cas, ce que je sais, c'est que
cette peur qu'on a voulu nous instyler
comme quoi il y aurait plus de pétrole,
c'était encore une de ces peurs qui sert
à nous diriger vers où on veut. Mais
parce que diriger par la peur, c'est
c'est apparemment une méthode de
gouvernement traditionnelle. Mais on
n'est pas en pénurie de pétrole. Non. Et
on n'est pas en pénurie d'uranium non
plus. Pierre, tu veux rajouter quelque
chose ou je pose ma question ? Non, mais
c'est c'est vrai que ça pose des
questions d'ordre géopolitique l'accès à
l'uranium. On parle de
Nouvelle-Calédonie, de choses comme ça,
de de de régions quand même lointaines.
Donc forcément, il y a des questions de
géopolitique derrière. Euh et l'accès à
l'énergie, c'est vrai qu'il est pas
également réparti, on est bien d'accord.
Bah de la même manière
que moi j'ai j'ai fait cette théorie dès
2017 et j'ai expliqué dès 2018 à
l'Assemblée nationale en France que il y
avait une grosse inégalité de traitement
du mining de Bitcoin en fonction du pays
dans lequel on est. En France, on avait
quand même de quoi se constituer une
réserve en Bitcoin parce qu'on avait une
ressource électrique complètement
dingue. On est quand même le quand je
t'ai dit tout à l'heure qu' DF a produit
430 TW en 2023, on se rend pas compte,
c'est juste gigantesque quoi. C'est la
plus grosse compagnie d'électricité au
monde en en capacité de produire un tel
volume d'électricité décarboné. Donc ce
que je voulais dire par là, c'est que
les acteurs déjà euh modernes en terme
de production d'électricité allaient
prendre encore un avantage concurrentiel
euh avec le Bitcoin et nous on a laissé
filer cet avantage concurrentiel. Si si
on regarde les chiffres, ça veut dire
qu'en gros avec les surplus français, on
aurait pu miner la moitié des Bitcoin
puisque c'est représente l'équivalent
bien sûr bien sûr de l'utilisation
électrique du du réseau Bitcoin.
Aujourd'hui, on pourrait ramasser la
moitié des bitcoins créés. Bon,
aujourd'hui, il y en a plus tant que ça
qui sont créés, mais quand même ça veut
dire qu'on est passé à côté d'une grosse
opportunité. On est passé à côté d'une
grosse créer les réserves pour le pays
et pour apprendre à domestiquer cet
outil qui est le mining et qui nous
servirait aujourd'hui beaucoup dans la
gestion de notre nucléaire. Donc
maintenant, on va finalement récupérer
l'outil parce que EDF va se mettre à
miner. Ça c'est pour moi une certitude.
Il y a un tel enjeu économique, il a un
tel enjeu de durée de nos nos réacteurs
que ça va se faire. Et donc on va on va
récupérer le mining de Bitcoin comme
outil euh alors qu'on aurait pu le
récupérer il y a 7 ans euh comme un
outil extrêmement productif en terme et
il y a 7 ans, il y avait il y aurait eu
beaucoup de Bitcoin. Il reste combien de
Bitcoin à aller chercher ? Euh un peu
plus d'un million je crois ou un peu
moins d'un million peut-être. On est
autour de 1 million. L'ordre de
grandeur, c'est 1 million mais ça veut
dire qu'il y en a beaucoup moins qu'il y
a 7 ans en tout cas en rester davantage
en tout cas il y a 7 ans. Quand tout
ceci sera
miné, qu'est-ce qu'on fera ? Nous on
sera mort, il faut bien le le
comprendre. Fin du
enfin on peut envisager que le le on
produira plus de Bitcoin à partir de
2140 et qu'avant on va produire vraiment
des pouillè de Bitcoin. Euh, on nous dit
depuis que j'ai commencé, moi que ça va
être insuffisant comme revenu pour faire
vivre nos installations. Finalement, le
mining rapporte de plus en plus, hein.
Et il y aura d'autres euh il y aura une
autre typologie de mineur en fait parce
que euh regarde le réseau courrier
électronique, il y a pas de minage
dessus, c'est gratuit, euh personne et
pourtant il y a des sociétés comme
Microsoft et Google qui qui contribuent
à faire tourner ce réseau. Donc faut pas
dire parce qu'il y a plus de Bitcoin à
créer, il y aura ça va s'arrêter parce
que plus personne aura d'intérêt. Si
tous ceux qui auront intérêt, ce sont
les gens qui auront un business de
paiement sur Bitcoin. Donc par exemple
ma société, d'autres on va miner comme
on entretient un réseau de paiement et
on prendra au passage des commissions de
réseau. Donc ce sera largement suffisant
pour continuer à assurer la sécurité.
L'enjeu, c'est la sécurité du réseau. Il
y aura toujours cette sécurité physique
parce que il y aura des gens qui vont
payer des factures d'électricité pour
faire tourner le réseau. Donc il y aura
les FIS mais aussi je l'explique aussi
depuis un moment le mining sera devenu
de plus en plus utile en tant qu'util
au-delà de ce qu'il va rapporter. Dans
l'étude que je fais pour EDF par
exemple, le gain attendu sur la
maintenance des centrales, sur
l'économie d'agent d'entretien, sur euh
l'amélioration de la performance est
supérieure à ce qu'on va produire en
Bitcoin. Et donc c'est le cas de Aircod,
on parlait du Texas tout à l'heure,
c'est pareil. Pour lui, c'est un outil
qui lui qui est qui offre un avantage
incroyable. En gros, depuis 3 ans qu'ils
ont adopté cet outil, ils ont plus de
blackout.
Donc c'est aussi simple que ça. Tu tu la
connais l'histoire d'Aircod ? Comment
c'est venu le mining ? En fait, le
mining s'est imposé de lui-même au Texas
parce que l'électricité avec le
programme de rachat d'électricité,
c'était déjà intéressant mais c'était
petit. En 2021, il y a eu un énorme
blackout. Je crois qu'il y a eu 300
morts hein, à cause de d'un hiver très
très particulier qui a qui a mis en
panne certaines centrales. Donc il y a
des centrales qui produisaient plus.
Bref, à ce moment-là, ils ont viré le
directeur d'Aircot. Ils ont ils ont fait
revenir l'ancien. Ils lui ont dit : "Tu
redeviens CO de manière provisoire." Et
donc lui a adopté le mining, lui a fait
la promotion du mining comme d'un outil
qui va qui allait permettre d'arrêter
les blackout. Il a dit au mineur "Venez,
venez, venez." Il faut bien savoir que
là-bas, il rachète le programme de de
demande de réponse. Là, c'est
extrêmement bien rémunéré. C'est-à-dire
que nous, on rêve que d'une chose, c'est
d'aller là-bas et de jamais faire
marcher notre ferme. Si elle marche
jamais, on gagne beaucoup plus d'argent
que si on mine. Mais en tout cas, à
l'aide de ce programme, le nouveau
patron de d'Arcot qui était donc
l'ancien patron d'Aircotte est redevenu
euh gérant de ce truclà et donc il
connaît ce succès là avec un réseau qui
est beaucoup mieux géré. Il y a plus de
blackout et il y en aura plus.
Vous parliez de sécurité, mexicanisation
et ainsi de suite. Vous voulez rajouter
un petit mot ou pas du tout ? Ah bah
c'est pas un petit mot hein. C'est là là
on tient un sujet qui peut nous on a
parlé de sécurité du réseau et là on
parle de sécurité physique. C'est ça
parce que ça fait partie de
l'effondrement euh de notre de notre
société.
Mais s'il y a quelques chiffres à donner
qui sont très faciles à comprendre pour
comprendre la déliquaisscence de notre
pays dans ce domaineelà, notre justice
travaille plus bien travaille plus comme
il faut. que ça c'est un c'est un
programme de modification de la justice
qui existe depuis les années 70 qui au
début était purement intellectuel et qui
a commencé à se concrétiser dans les
faits à partir des années 90 et on a vu
des tout un tas de progrès pour les
victimes où on a personnalisé les
peines, où on a commencé à remplacer les
petites peines de prison par des peines
de substitution au début TIG puis
bracelet électronique qui a été imposé
non pas pour la gauche mais par Rachit
Adati et sa première ministre de
l'époque Michel Alomariie. Donc on a
commencé à remplacer et la prison. La
prison est devenue le truc de dernier
recours et on en arrive à un problème
complètement identifiable en trois
chiffres. Le premier chiffre c'est en
2022, la Cour des comptes a relevé que
il y avait en France à un momenté 120000
pelmes de prison qui n'étaient pas
effectués. C'est-à-dire que tu as 120000
mecs qui devraient être en tô et qui n'y
sont pas à un momenté tout le temps.
Au-delà de ça, aujourd'hui tu as 355000
personnes euh qui sont à leur 10e
récidive.
355000 parmi cela, tu en as euh qui sont
à au-delà de 5 récidives. Parmi ceux-là,
tu en as 88000 qui sont au-delà de 10
récidives. C'est quoi tes sources ? Bah
regarde
sur je j'ai pas besoin de donner mes
sources ici. Tout est face checké donc
je suis sûr de bon coup.
Euh c'est le ministère de la justice
entre autres hein, la cour des comptes.
Il y a des comptes Twitter qui
reprennent ces stats. Mais sur les 1200
c'est la cour des comptes. 2022 il y
avait 120000 personnes euh qui devaient
être en prison qui n'étaient pas en
prison. C'est c'est très grave ce l'axis
de la justice. Pourquoi on en arrive à
des chiffres comme ça complètement
délirant ? 355000 personnes qui ont plus
de cinq condamnations et qui sont
toujours dehors parce que justement on a
décidé qu'on allait plus mettre les gens
en prison. La problématique, si demain
tu es condamné à 11 mois de prison, tu
as fait une grosse connerie, tu as
défoncé un mec dans la rue, handicap et
tout, tu prends 11 mois de prison ferme.
À moins que tu as un mandat de dépôt à
ta sortie du tribunal, tu ne vas pas en
prison. Tu rentres chez toi et tu
attends que l'administration
pénitentiaire t'envoie ton
emprisonnement, ta convocation. Ta mise
au fert. Ta mise au fert. Si pendant 4
ans tu la reçois pas, c'est fini. Tu
pourras plus jamais faire de prison sur
cette condamnation là, j'entends. Voilà.
Sauf que les juges d'application des
peines mettent plus de temps que ça pour
travailler et donc ces peinesl sont
jamais faites et les délinquants le
savent.
Donc euh leurs avocats ça le jeu même
quand le jeu en voit pas la chandelle le
banditisme tu vois par exemple aller
enlever la fille de pierre il y a une
chance sur 1000 que ça donne de l'argent
hein. C'est c'est une énorme connerie de
faire ça parce que non seulement c'est
pas facile d'enlever quelqu'un mais une
fois que tu l'as le chantage fonctionne
pas bien. Donc tu as très peu de chance
de gagner de l'argent avec ça. Mais
comme tu as aussi très peu de chance
d'être puni par la justice bah le jeu
envoie la chandelle d'un coup. Donc euh
ça c'est un
véritable euh c'est un véritable danger
pour notre société. C'est pas du tout
normal les chiffres. Enfin, j'entendez
un un commissaire divisionnaire là sur
un podcast tout à l'heure, il disait
"Quand j'ai commencé jeune flic il y a
40 ans de ça, euh comme je t'ai dit les
chiffres, il y avait 500000 crimés
d'Alli en France par an. Aujourd'hui,
c'est entre 5 et 8 millions. Quelle est
notre réponse judiciaire ? Tout le monde
dehors avec un brass électronique. Si
jamais on a le temps de lui mettre le
brass électronique parce que c'est pas
encore sûr, ça va pas. Il y a quelque
chose qui va pas.
Ouais, c'est ça. C'est ce que dit, je
pense que Seb adressé le tableau en
gros. C'estd qu'en gros, tu as une
approche idéologique de la justice
aujourd'hui qui n'est pas pragmatique au
sens comment on est protégé en fait.
Donc aujourd'hui, on est mis en danger
par des idéologues euh sur des bases
effectivement idéologiques des années 70
hein. Alors que dans le même temps, la
criminalité augmenté par 10 par 20. Euh
on a il y a quasiment pas de nouvelles
place de prison enfin très peu. Donc
effectivement de 400 à même si on
voulait mettre les gens en prison, on
construit plus de place de prison. Donc
et je parle de la prison. Alors les
gens, les idéologues ont l'habitude de
d'utiliser la morale comme vraiment le
prisme d'analyse principale, c'est la
morale, le bien et le mal. Est-ce que
c'est bien de mettre les gens en prison
? Non, c'est pas bien. Vaut mieux
essayer de les réinsérer et cetera.
Moi je je effectivement je préconiserai
une approche plus pragmatique et
empirique. C'est qu'effectivement si
quelqu'un est en prison, il va pas venir
me m'agresser ou agresser mes enfants.
Et si c'est s'il a récidivé 10 10 fois,
j'ai pas envie d'être la 11e fois en
fait. C'est ça. Donc à partir de là, tu
comprends que la prison a une utilité
publique. Mais à aucun moment on va
parler de punition en fait. On va juste
parler de mettre en sécurité les
citoyens. Euh et c'est cette approche là
que moi je voudrais voir émerger dans
l'offre politique en France et j'ai un
peu de mal à la voir venir. Il y a pas
la volonté politique, tu vois, on a
entendu parce que ça rapporte pas de
voix en fait ce que tu disais ça. On se
fait pas élire sur la promesse de
construire des des places de prison
parce que tout le monde s'imagine ça
n'arrive qu'aux autres. Sauf que ça
arrive à de plus en plus de gens
aujourd'hui. Ça arrive à de plus en plus
de gens. Je peux en témoigner. Donc,
mais j'avais cette conviction bien avant
que que effectivement il y ait les
événements don dont on a parlé. Donc euh
politiquement ça marche pas et quand et
surtout ils ont perdu la foi quandmanin
euh qui a toujours été un un père
fouettard une fois qu'il est ministre
enfin qu'il est garde des sauts euh les
places de prison on peut en faire 500
quoi. Il dit la problématique de faire
des places de prison en France c'est
qu'il faut 7 ans. Boué il a mis 7 mois
pour faire 40000 places de prison au
Salvador. C'est qui Beleé ? C'est quoi
le Salvador ? C'est pas le petit état
qui utilise du Bitcoin. Absolument.
C'est un état d'Amérique centrale. Oui,
c'est ça. Qui était envahi par les gang,
enfin qui était complètement corrompu
par la mafia, qui dirigeait tout le pays
vraiment et et donc qui connaissait une
criminalité hallucinante avec un nombre
de morts délirant. Et donc Bouquelé a a
changé le profil du pays en en sissant
et donc en construisant des prisons et
en mettant des cripels en prison. et le
préalable euh parce que maintenant c'est
la paix sociale dans le pays hein,
vraiment le tu vois moi mon projet
familial est de partir y habiter. On a
acheté un appart là-bas parce que j'ai
quatre enfants et que là-bas je sens
qu'ils sont en sécurité. Ils sont en
sécurité. On y passe pratiquement la
moitié de l'année aujourd'hui. Une
chambre d'amis. Ouais. Ouais. J'aurais
une chambre d'amis mais le pays est sûr.
Et donc comment il en est arrivé là ? Il
y avait deux préalables. Il a viré les
juges permissifs. Il les a mis en prison
euh en retraite pardon. les a pas mis en
prison, il les a juste mis en retraite.
Ça suffit, ça suffit. Et il a construit
des places de prison et c'était
clairement identifié la problématique du
pays dans un ouvrage de son oncle à Boué
qui était un un chirurgien assez célèbre
là-bas et intellectuel qui avait écrit
dès les années 90 que le Salvador ne
pourrait s'en sortir qu'environ ses
juges en construisant des places de
prison. Et donc c'est ce qu'il a fait
euh Naï Bouquelé quand il est arrivé au
pouvoir et c'est il s'avère que c'est
très efficace hein et que la population
en est très reconnaissante.
C'est c'est une solution qui a marché.
Alors encore une fois ce qu'on disait
sur les politiques aujourd'hui ils sont
voilà on va nous expliquer que c'est un
petit pays alors qu'on est un grand
pays. On va nous expliquer que c'est pas
démocratique alors que nous on est
démocratique. Moi la dernière fois que
j'ai regardé on était pas si
démocratique que ça hein. Notamment avec
des organes de censure comme l'ARCOM et
cetera. Donc non, j'ai pas l'impression
qu'on soit tellement plus démocratique
queeux. Et en terme de taille du pays,
je vois pas le rapport les statistiques.
Voilà, il faut juste on a un territoire
plus grand aussi pour construire des
prisons. Donc en terme de de présence
par rapport à la par habitant, on va
être sur les mêmes ratios et et en tout
cas, il y a une solution qui a marché.
Donc on va, j'entends certains dire faut
surtout pas essayer parce que ça a
marché en fait. Oui, c'est un peu ça.
Euh et et donc Bellé, il a remis en
question
cette cette vision de la prison en
dernier recours. Euh et ça gêne beaucoup
les mondialistes, tu vois le Bellé a
pris une telle levée de bouclier.
Pourquoi on le traite de de dictateur
aujourd'hui et pourquoi lui-même a fini
par dire "Oui, je suis le dictateur le
plus cool du monde ?" C'est pas parce
que lui se désigne en tant que
dictateur, c'est parce que la presse de
Soros l'a désigné comme telle. C'est
quoi la presse de Sorous ? Ben, c'est la
presse que finance l'Open Society de
George Soros.
C'est pas Alors, les gens pensent que
c'est complotiste de dire ça, mais par
exemple le principal journal
d'opposition au Salvador, El Faro est
financé à 25 % directement par l'Open
Society. Sans parler des hausses
financement qui arrivent plus ou moins
occules aussi de l'Open Society, mais
dans les comptes, c'est clair, l'Open
Society donne 25 % du budget total d'El
Pharo qui passe son temps à dire que la
politique de Bouquellé est une politique
fasciste de dictature et tout ça. Il
faut de la pluralité, il faut des
subventions pour la
presse. Qui te dit que ils reçoivent pas
l'argent ? Ils reçoivent l'argent mais
que ils ne gardent pas cette conscience
journalistique, cette dévotion vers la
presse et la charte de Munique. Ben, je
suis d'accord avec toi, a priori, on
peut tout à fait être financé par
quelque organisme que ce soit sans laver
les mains et garder sa ligne de
conduite. Tout à fait. Donc, c'est ton
interprétation que Soros influence leur
ligne éditoriale. Absolument. parce que
mon interprétation est basée sur des
faits et sur la ligne éditoriale
éditoriale en question. Il suffit de le
lire pour avoir la mauvaise foi
permanente. Il y a eu un documentaire
qui est paru la semaine dernière sur la
politique de Bouquellé et le régime
d'exception sur Rarteté. Mais c'est de
la folie en fait. C'est 20 minutes où on
dit aux électeurs allemands et aux
électeurs français voyez ne faites pas
le choix de l'ordre c'est trop dangereux
quoi. En gros, ils disent que toute la
population salvadorienne elle a peur au
ventre de finir en prison. En fait,
c'est peut-être vrai. Oui, bien sûr. J'y
habite un peu la moitié de l'année. Donc
je veux dire que s'il y a une peur
aujourd'hui qui subsiste chez les
Salvadorien, c'est que ça recommence.
C'est que Bouclé n'aille pas jusqu'au
bout de sa mission, qu'il arrête sa
lutte contre les gangs et qu'il en
oublie un ou deux. Ils vont faire
renaître le truc. Décrire, pour décrire
euh euh faut rentrer dans les détails un
peu. Donc les gangs en Amérique du Sud,
c'est un peu comme au Brésil, au
Mexique, en Uruguay. Uruguay peut-être
un peu moins
mais c'est euh à l'ancienne archaïque,
on rentre peut-être pas trop dans le
détail mais euh il te il te renvoi un
petit morceau, ils te font chanter, on
parle d'expérience parce que on avait
une
amie, son père était colonel au Mexique
et son petit
nom était très tiré de ça parce qu'il
s'est fait kidnapper, ils ont demandé
une rançon, ça a mis du temps et donc
c'est très très compliqué. quand il
allait se balader au Mexique, il est
obligé de se balader en fourgon blindé
avec une voiture devant, une voiture
derrière et que ça prenait des
proportions dramatiques parce que les
mecs étaient lourdement armé pour aller
le chercher et que il s'intéressait à
toute la famille. Au au chez Bouquelé,
ça prenait quelle tournure ? C'était du
de la petite rapine, de la grosse
rapine, du narcotrafic. Ça ressemblait à
quoi ? Bah ça ressemblait à un état
mafieux en fait. Ils avaient pris le
pouvoir sur pratiquement toute
l'activité économique. C'est tu pouvais
pas être boulanger, marchand de légume
ou quelle que soit ton activité
d'entrepreneur sans cracher un impôt à
la mafia. L'exemple le plus flagrant,
moi quand j'ai commencé à y aller en
2021, tu avais encore des gardes armées
devant toutes les boutiques. Mais
boutiques de lingerie, station service,
n'importe quelle boutique. Qu'est-ce que
tu entends par armée avec un petit bâton
? Non non, un garde armée avec un fusil
à pompe euh ou une galage mais en
général c'était le fusil à pompe. H il
savait il pouvait s'en servir ou c'était
juste pour le folklore ? Moi, j'ai
jamais vu quelqu'un tirer avec, mais euh
a priori, oui, c'est des vrais fusils à
pompe. Ça c'était systématiquement des
organisations mafieuses qui imposer le
vigile aux commerçants. C'estàd que si
tu prends pas mon vigile, bah tu vas
voir, c'est compangereux de pas avoir de
vigile. Donc, tu avais les vigiles
devant les écoles qui étaient des
organisations mafieuses. La police de
Bouqueller, ils ont trouvé une ruse. Il
y a une loi qui existe au Salvador qui
fait que ton arme, elle doit
être révisée par la
préfecture. Enfin, l'identification doit
être renouvelée par la préfecture tous
les 5 ans, je crois ou 3 ans. Et donc
ben ils ont fait le contrôle de tous ces
trucs là et toutes leurs armes étaient
pas en règle. Donc ils ont la police a
pris les armes des des vigiles mais les
vigiles de la mafia étaient devant
toutes les écoles du Salvador. Ça s'est
fait en combien de temps la récupération
des armes ? 3 ans je dirais. 2 3 ans
même pas. Même pas.
En fait, tu sais, il a commencé sa
politique répressive dès qu'il a été élu
en 2019 et en 2021, les gangs ont relevé
la tête. Ils ont dit "Non, c'est nous
qui avons le pouvoir dans ce pays."
Pendant tout un weekend, ils ont tué des
gens. Ils ont tué pas loin de 100
personnes sur un samedi et un dimanche.
Ils ont tué n'importe qui. Des élèves à
la sortie de l'école, marchandes de
fleurs ont marché. Enfin, c'est la
terreur. Ils ont dit "C'est nous qui
allons faire la terreur." Et Bouquel a
réagi en disant "Non, non, je vais être
beaucoup plus terrible que vous." Et là,
ils ont vraiment déclenché l'opération
actuelle euh donc qui est le régime
d'acception qui est très critiqué par
les ONG euh et qui permet effectivement
d'avoir des
arrestations euh sans jugement hein, ce
qui est assez normal. Ils jugent les
gens, ils les arrêtent d'abord, ils font
de la préventive, quelque chose qui est
assez connu chez nous, mais qui est
systématisé sur les les pandillas, les
maraces, enfin tous ceux qui sont
suspectés d'en faire partie, si tu veux
là-bas, ils ont une facilité énorme,
c'est qu'ils sont tatoués. Il tatou et
il tatou sur leur corps. J'ai violé
trois femmes, 5 12, j'ai tué 15
personnes. Donc euh voilà les il y a une
police qui est assez euh entraîné à lire
ses tatouages et qui se trompe pas. Ah
moi j'ai un voisin à Elsoné qui est
couvert de tatouage et il me faisait
tout le temps flipper parce que je
pensais que c'était un un de ses gangs.
Et bon ben petit à petit, j'ai discuté
avec son frère qui lui ait pas de
tatouage et tout ça. Il dit non non
c'est juste un artiste. Il est tatoué
depuis toujours. Euh parce que je lui
disais mais comment ça se fait que la
police l'arrête pas quoi ? Non mais ils
sont pas cons les policiers, ils ont
bien vu que voilà tout le monde le
connaît dans le village depuis toujours.
On sait bien que c'est pas un un membre
de pousser ses tomates. Voilà et c'est
et sûrement pas que mais en tout cas euh
ils ont une une politique répressive qui
a été facilitée par ça. Ouais. Par le
par la présence des tatouages. Mais
surtout bon à peu près tout le monde
savait euh qui étaient les gangs et
jusque- là bah la la justice avait
laissé tomber. Ils sont remontés à la
tête de ceux qui récupéraient le pognon.
C'estàd qu'il devait forcément y avoir
des politiques bien sûr qui étaient
mouillé là-dedans. Non, sûr, bien sûr,
bien sûr. Il y a une il y a une
opération main propre au Salvador qui
est juste dedans. Je sais pas si tu as
vu, il y a 2 ans, il a carrément dit en
plein conseil des ministres euh vous
avez nous sommes tous ici payés par le
gouvernement sauf le monsieur là qui est
le procureur principal du pays et donc
il est en train de faire une enquête sur
chacun d'entre nous. Voilà. Et certains
qui se décomposaient, tu voyais déjà les
corrompus. Donc ouais et puis tous les
gros chefs maieux sont sont partis au
COD sont sont enfermés. La politique
répressive a été vraiment très très
efficace. Ouais très efficace. Pierre,
tu veux rebondir ? Bah je trouve qu'il y
a une grande cohérence en tout cas entre
son approche pragmatique de la justice
et son approche pragmatique du domaine
monétaire. C'est qu'en gros Bitcoin
c'est une expérimentation qui marche.
C'est ce qu'on dit hein. Ça marche.
Voilà, on est toujours en version 0
point et quelque chose sur Bitcoin.
C'est on dit tous c'est une
expérimentation mais sauf qu'elle
fonctionne et la sur la justice j'ai
l'impression qu'il fait il fait il a la
même approche pragmatique c'est on essae
quelque chose en espérant que ça marche
puis si ça marche on continue. Surtout
quand tu es au fond du trou en fait là
ils étaient au fond du trou au niveau
sécuritaire au niveau monétaire ils
n'ont plus de monnaie le Salvador depuis
les années 80 donc ils ont que le dollar
américain. Donc ça vait le coup de faire
cette expérience qui est vraiment une
expérience qui s'ajuste au jour le jour.
Les gens nous disent Bitcoin est plus
monnaie légal au Salvador ? Ben si. Euh
mais simplement ils sont en train
d'inventer le modèle de monnaie légale
sur le Bitcoin. C'est le seul pays donc
c'est lui qui invente son modèle. Parce
que les gens t'opposent, les commerçants
sont pas obligés de l'accepter. Donc ça
on ne peut pas dire que c'est une
monnaie légale dans la définition. Mais
la définition des monaies légales dépend
des monnaies fiates. Elle est pas faite
en fonction de cette nouvelle offre de
monnaie. Ça a aucun sens pour Bitcoin.
le sens la notion de monnaie et en cours
légal n'a aucun sens pour parce qu'il y
a pas d'autorité souveraines qui les
met. Donc donc là euh on commence à être
opérationnel, l'apéritif de l'interview
a
commencé. Donnez-moi cinq risques que
vous avez identifié en Europe ou dans le
monde ou cinq choses qui vous
inquiètent.
Bah, on a déjà parlé de la sécuriche de
la sécurité dans les rues. Donc
effectivement, c'est quand même la base
un peu de voilà du de la démocratie, de
la confiance sociale dont on parlait.
Euh donc la démocratie peut-être en
deuxème parce que effectivement je la
trouve un peu chancelante moi en ce
moment des trucs qui étaient impensables
quand j'étais enfant quoi. Enfin la
censure, j'ai l'impression un peu de
l'Allemagne de l'Est. Moi, je suis né
dans les années du mur de Berlin dit que
l'Arcom était un organisme de censure.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi tout point de vue
fact ? Bah de facto il font des
conneries aussi sont c'est le gendarme.
Oui, mais il y a on a l'impression qu'il
y a un double standard quand même parce
qu'on voit des dérives dans certains
médias qui sont pas sanctionnés. C'est
toujours un peu voilà les dérives
d'extrême gauche apparemment c'est cool.
Mais dès qu'il y a une dérive qui
ressemble un peu qui est pas qui est pas
en cohérence avec l'idéologie d'extrême
gauche, ça va plus du tout. Donc euh on
voit bien cette espèce de de connivance
entre l'extrême centre et l'extrême
gauche qui est extrêmement menaçante
pour la démocratie parce que ça veut
dire qu'on a là un bloc euh majoritaire
du coup si on a l'extrême centre et
l'extrême gauche euh
et dans les années 30 en Allemagne
c'était la peste brune mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on a la peste rouge dans
les années 2020 on a des gens qui ont
les mêmes caractéristiques que la peste
brune c'est antisémite avec des milices
qui mettent des cibles dans le dos de
leurs opposants qui interdisent des
médias, enfin il cochent à peu près
toutes les cases quand même de de des
années 30 en Allemagne. Euh donc ça ça
commence à faire beaucoup et je trouve
que ça devient inquiétant. B tout va
dans le même sens en fait. C'est comme
le fait de de maquiller les indicateurs.
On est dans un monde qui est qui est en
train de s'écrouler enfin en tout cas
dans un dans une organisation européenne
qui est en train de s'écrouler et donc
bah pour éviter l'écroulement, on sert
les vis bien sûr. Donc on va devenir de
plus en plus autoritaire. Tu as quand
même une population qui s'est soulevée
il y a 5 ans 6 ans parce que le gazoile
était passé à 1 dollar 1 € aujourd'hui
il est à 2 € on tient les gens tac on
aura dit vous voulez aller
manifester 30 et borniers tu vois donc
oui oui la répression tu as raison la
répression des gilets jaunes quand on la
compare à la réal pourir chez soi pour
aller manifester Pierre Pierre quand on
la compare à la répression des émeutes
où là c'est plutôt l'extrême gauche
qu'il aurait fallu il aurait fallu taper
sur leurs amis d'extrême gauche pas
tapé. Ouais, enfin ils auraient ils
auraient été un peu en opposition avec
leurs alliés de l'extrême gauche. On
voit bien que l'extrême centre a
clairement choisi son camp et ça ça
c'est quand même assez inquiétant et
tout ça est très horswilien au sens de
l'inversion du sens des mots. C'est par
exemple antifasciste antifar faut savoir
que le mur de Berlin il s'appelait
antifascistici Shoots and roll. C'est
c'est le c'est le mur de protection
antifasciste, tu vois, c'est ça le mot
la désignation officielle par les
communistes du mur de Berlin, le mur de
protection antifasciste. Donc
aujourd'hui, les gens qui emploient le
mot antifasciste, ils me font très peur
parce qu'ils parlent comme les Allemands
de l'Est, le régime d'Allemagne de l'Est
dans les années. On parle pas tous comme
ça. Ah antifasciste si quand même parce
que tous leurs ennemis politiques sont
fascistes. Donc ça veut dire que si tu
penses pas comme eux, c'est ça ?
leurs ennemis politiques. Donc c'est
tous ceux qui pensent pas comme eux,
c'est leurs ennemis politiques et c'est
des ils sont fascistes. Donc c'est eux
les antifascistes. Et ça c'est très
inquiétant quand les gens commencent à
se présenter comme antifasciste. Et et
donc ce côté hwélien d' c'est le sens
des mots la victime et le coupable c'est
on inverse la victime et le coupable où
il y a il y a égalité des droits. Alors
ça aussi c'est une dérive du droit. Si
on le danger c'est le juridisme aussi.
Euh la démocratie peut mourir du
juridisme. Le juridisme c'est quoi ?
C'est l'écosystème du droit qui s'empare
de qui qui prend le contrôle de la
société. Aujourd'hui, j'ai l'impression
que c'est un peu ça qui se passe. On a
parlé de du monopole monétaire où en
droit, il est il est il est maintenu par
le l'écosystème du droit, mais dans les
faits, non. Avec Bitcoin, il est plus
là. Donc on voit bien les les dangers du
juridisme et puis euh euh aussi euh par
exemple hein, je je l'illustre si tu
veux l'égalité des droit quasiment entre
euh l'accusé et la victime. Je parle pas
de d'une querelle de voisinage avec un
sur un mur mitoyen où là l'égalité des
droits, le juge va dire bon c'est de qui
joue avec son téléphone, il en a rien à
[__] de je cherche une citation pour
illustrer ce qu'il a dit. C'est des deux
voisins qui qui sont dans une dispute.
C'est c'est mais sur le pénal où il y a
des fesses si tu veux avérer de de
criminalité, de violence et où tu
t'aperçois qu'en fait la partie adverse,
c'estàd le gars qui a le le gangster ou
le gang, il a accès au dossiers, c'est
aux informations de l'enquête. Donc il
va savoir ce que pour se défendre, ils
vont soi-disant pour se défendre. Mais
en fait non, il va savoir ce que font
les enquêteurs. Donc il va pouvoir la
fois d'après son petit trafic, il va
pouvoir l'ajuster parce qu'il a eu accès
au dossier et il a les mêmes droits donc
que toi qui est la victime en fait. Tu
vois ce que je veux dire ?
Là c'est un truc c'est du ça c'est ce
que j'appelle du juridisme c'est un truc
quand le droit devient fou alors moi je
veux bien qu'il a accès au dossier à
certains éléments du dossier
certainement pas du dossier je me fais
l'avocat du diable Imagine-toi que tu
tombes dans un gouvernement totalement
totalitaire et que bon bah on te dise
toi tu es coupable et puis on va pas
t'expliquer comment te défendre et on va
pas te donner le tes chefs d'accusation
ou ce qu'on te reproche donc tu peux pas
te défendre c'est quand même mais là
hypothèse ton hypothèse c'est on est
dans un gouvernement totalitaire donc
c'est ce que je suis en train de dire
c'est qu'on est plus on est on est
proche de de cette situation en fait à
partir moment où les où les criminels si
tu veux c'est ce que disait Sol Genitin
à propos des des du régime communiste.
Il disait c'est on reconnaît un régime
un régime communiste au fait que les
criminels ont plus de droits que les
opposants
politiques. Tu vois c'est c un autre
truc aussi. Ouais, il a dit plein de
trucs
mais on va on va pas évoquer sa mémoire
mais vas-y si tu veux le citer pas quand
tu prends ton sourire de Joker comme ça
Seb qu'est-ce qu'il a dit ? Il disait
pas on sait qu'il mente ils savent qu'il
qu'il mentent qu'il nous mentent et je
te laisse terminer Seb.
Non j'ai c'est c'est peut-être pas lui.
Si si. Non mais je vois bien la mais je
l'ai lu en russe moi. Si c'est tu parles
russe ? Non du tout.
Je
décon donc on était en train de dire que
effectivement un régime qui commence à
faire la parbelle au criminel en droit
euh c'est peut-être qu'il est il est
peut-être sur une mauvaise pente et
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que c'est
un peu ce qui se passe quand même et ça
c'est le juridisme c'est c'est quand les
avocats et les juges commencent à former
un écosystème à part entière où
effectivement alors le droit là on parle
d'inflation normative souvent mais alors
le droit c'est voilà ils produisent des
textes des mots chaque année il y a plus
de mots donc on on est de plus en plus
dépend en deux en fait à cause de toute
cette abondance de mots qu'il faut
maîtriser et et ça devient vraiment
problématique. Alors, je me refais
l'avocé du diable parce qu'il faut aussi
défendre la justice. Il y a des juges
qui font bien leur boulot. Il y a des
enquêteurs qui font bien leur boulot. Il
y a des avocats qui ne sont pas pourris
et que ils sont pas Tu vois, c'est
important de mettre ou il y a des
poissons qui volent aussi. Bien sûr.
Oui, c'est pas les poissons
volants. Et tu sais pourquoi ils volent
? parce qu'ils ont peur de se faire
bouffer et donc ils ont développé des
des voilà tu me déconcentres ça existe
mais c'est pas la majorité des c'est pas
la majorité voilà c'est vrai c'est un
peu comme oui les éléphants c'est c'est
bon façon arrêtez de me déconcentrer les
gars
quand je t'entends parler de ça j'ai
l'impression que tu as une dent est-ce
que ça fait partie du fait que tu t'es
fait un peu secouer récemment
honnêtement j'en avais conscience avant
les événements qui qui m'ont touché
personnellement
euh les on m'a demandé effectivement
est-ce que je suis surpris euh est-ce
que je suis pris pris par surprise ?
Alors qu'en fait je dis je dis ce que je
te dis là, je disais il y a déjà 2 ans
hein, c'était pas c'est pas d'hier que
cette dérive du juridisme en tout cas
euh peut être constatée et la démocratie
est vraiment mise en danger par ce cette
dérive. Euh comme disait Montesieux, il
faut écrire la loi avec une main
tremblante. Euh il faut en rajouter avec
une main tremblante. Bitcoin c'est très
proche de Montescu en fait
philosophiquement hein. C'est pas
Rousseau, pas du tout. C'est très
intéressant dans le sens où euh je
discute avec des entrepreneurs du
Bitcoin. Comme vous le savez, on aim
écouter tous les sons de cloche. Ceux
qui pensent que le Bitcoin n'est pas ses
câble ou des choses comme
ça. Quand je vous entends surtout,
j'étais très surpris que tu écrit un
bouquin entre la relation de cause à
effet entre monnaie, PIB et énergie. Seb
est quand même un peu affuté sur ce
sujet-là par rapport au
KIDAM. Quel regard vous portez sur cette
société mondialisée où les tensions se
augmentent ? Je vous entendais que
j'entendais que on est près proche des
années 30. On sait tout ce qui s'est
passé après quand on entend l'Allemagne
se réarmer 1000 milliards que les Russes
veulent nous faire notre fête et pas que
les Américains veulent nous faire notre
fête mais d'une façon un peu plus
sournoise que les Chinois sont en
embuscade avec leur roule au compresseur
de
stratège. Nous petit français
Cocorico la main sur de
Gaulle, on se parle franchement.
Est-ce que nos hommes politiques, notre
classe politique, est-ce qu'ils sont à
la hauteur de l'histoire
? Là, je pense que la réponse est un peu
dans ta
question. En fait, moi si j'aime bien le
régime politique suisse, c'est parce
qu'on sait pas qui dirige la Suisse.
Moi, je voudrais sa qui dirige la
Suisse, c'est les Suisses. Suis voilà.
Exactement. Bah, si on pouvait arriver à
ça en France, ce serait génial. C'estàd
arrêter de considérer qu'il faut voilà
une espèce de successeur à de Gaulle. De
Gaulle, il a émergé dans des années très
particulières, dans des circonstances
très particulières dans un monde dans
dans le monde au 21e siècle. C'est c'est
plutôt un régime c'est pas la 5e
République, ça c'est sûr qu'il nous
faut. C'est c'est plutôt un régime
décentralisé. C'est pas un Bitcoin
évidemment qui qui va dire le contraire.
Donc je parle de décentralisation
monétaire mais ça va de avec une
décentralisation politique. Donc la
logique de Bitcoin c'est d'avoir un
gouvernement à la Suisse où tu sais pas
qui gouverne et où tu
tu as le principe de subsidiarité.
C'estàd que tout ce que tu peux décider
au niveau local, tu le décides au niveau
local. Ça se passe en Suisse là
récemment. Ils cherchent à changer les
règles en terme de majorité de canton.
Ils ont un problème parce qu'ils sont
rentrés dans le Schengen, je crois en
2008. Donc de toute façon le je dirais
le verre est dans le fruit. à partir du
moment où tu rentres dans Schengen, euh
tu rentres dans un machin qui est plus
c'est plus exactement la Suisse d'avant
puisque du coup tu as plus la notion de
frontière. Les frontières c'est quoi ?
C'est des c'est des informations qui
réduisent l'entropie. Encore une fois,
s'il y a des frontières, c'est que ta
maison a des murs et une porte que tu
peux contrôler. À partir du moment, il y
a plus de frontières. C'est la les mondi
Tu dis les mondialistes. Moi, je dis les
sans frontièistes, c'est un peu la même
chose. Les sans frontièistes ont oublié
le concept d'entropie. Effectivement,
s'il y a plus de frontière, ça veut dire
qu'il y a un gouvernement mais il est
quelque part très loin et tu le connais
pas. Donc ça c'est veut dire qu'on a
augmenté ton entropie, ton incertitude
par rapport à l'avenir parce qu'il va se
décider ailleurs. Tu auras pas de prise
sur ton avenir. Donc ça je c'est
contraire au troisème principe qui est
que dire toi en tant que structure
dissipative, tu veux réduire ton
entropie. Donc tu veux tu veux un des
frontières autour de toi, tu veux une
maison avec des murs et une porte, tu
veux pas que n'importe qui puisse
rentrer dans ton salon et s'installer,
bah c'est pareil pour un pays. Il y a le
principe de subsidiarité, il y a la il y
a l'appartement éventuellement, la
maison et puis le le pays. Donc le sans
frontièisme est générateur d'anxiété
pour les humains. Tu as déjà été tu as
déjà essayé de t'installer dans le salon
d'un Corse sans son autorisation ?
Voilà, c'est ça. Bah c'est la Suisse et
les Corses, ils ont des quelques points
commun. Effectivement, il y a une les
Cor se sont bien décentralisées par
rapport à Paris, je trouve.
Je trouve que tous les en fait tous les
départements devrait suivre le même
modèle. Oui. Et à ce momentlà, on
s'apercevrait que Macron sert à rien et
ça c'est le job qu'il lui faut. Là,
c'est plus euh moi pour euh je me
permets hein, attention, pas de bêtises,
hein. Non, non, mais comme tu disais,
est-ce que on a des politiques des
hommes politiques à la hauteur, à la de
gaule et tout, je crois que c'est c'est
pas le sujet hein. Euh il y en a
certainement qui ont du talent mais
aujourd'hui, ils arrivent pas à
l'exprimer parce qu'ils ont ils ont plus
du tout le pouvoir
quoi. Enfin, en tout cas, tu parles des
banques qui financent les partis
politiques entre autres. Entre autres,
mais je veux dire même une fois qu'ils
sont élus, tu vois, d'abord la vraie
bataille se joue au moment de l'élection
effectivement.
et du financement des campagnes, des
médias et tout ça. Et après, il faut
avoir les coups d'étrange pour mener une
politique aujourd'hui. Moi, je me mets
quand tu disais, est-ce que tu te mets à
leur place ? Oui, je me mets à leur
place. Ils sont totalement
impuissants. C'est ils sont ils sont
obligés de lutter contre l'Union
européenne si et ça c'est une vraie
problématique. Si tu veux que la France
sorte son épingle du jeu, on doit on
doit désobéir en permanence aux
directives de l'Union européenne. Donc
là, il y a bien un véritable problème.
Je dis pas qu'il faut sortir demain de
l'Union européenne. En tout cas, on doit
reprendre le lead et dire "C'est pas de
cette Europe là qu'on veut. Ni vous, ni,
ni vous non plus. Personne ne veut de
cette Union européenne là." Sauf les
gars qui bossent à Bruxelles. Sauf les
gars qui bossent à Bruxelles. Pierre
parler des médias. On en profite pour
dire à notre communauté, financez-vous.
Sans vous, on pourra pas tenir parce que
on vous passe les détails du nombre
d'attaques qu'on attaque, qu'on se prend
dans la tête, que ce soit à gauche, à
droite, au centre, des anglais, des mecs
des
des mecs payés par les anglais ou par à
gauche à droite, je vous donc
soutenez-nous sur Tipi, on a vraiment
besoin de vous. Euh question
internet. Comment le Bitcoin peut-il
résoudre les problématiques des
inégalités de richesse
? Ah, c'est intéressant parce que d'où
vi d'où viendraient les inégalités de
richesse ? Euh est-ce que euh est-ce que
tout le monde prend les mêmes risques
dans son métier ? Par exemple, je moi je
vois des policiers, des médecins qui
font qui sont en face du public,
d'autres gens qui sont dans un bureau
par exemple. Bon bah, ils ont pas le
même niveau de risque. Du coup, est-ce
qu'ils doivent être payés la même chose
? Pers ouf, les pompiers par exemple,
les infirmières, ça c'est des gens qui
sont en première ligne. Est-ce qu'ils
sont voilà, est-ce les agriculteurs,
est-ce qu'ils sont rémunérés par exemple
à la hauteur de ce qui de leur
contribution à la société ? Je suis pas
sûr. Pour moi, la question c'est plutôt
celle-là parce que les inégalités, elles
sont inhérentes à la nature humaine. On
n'est pas égau dans le devant le notre
capacité de travail, notre capacité
d'apprentissage et cetera. Non mais
regarde, tu es pas é tu es pas égal à
moi. Si je me lève, je te je te colle
une Exactement. Exactement. Il y a plein
de gens qui sont plus forts que moi dans
plein de domaines. Moi, tu es un
cerveau. Mais non, mais pas dans tous
les domaines. C'est là où il y a une
complémentarité. Trouver sa place dans
la société et être un individu
responsable, c'est trouver sa place dans
la société pour y faire une contribution
positive. C'est pas juste être un
assisté. C'est ce que disait Kennedy en
disant que vous demandez pas ce que
l'État peut faire pour vous, mais dem
demandez-vous ce que vous pouvez faire
pour pour votre pays. Euh c'est
exactement ça que j'aurais envie de dire
aujourd'hui. Qu'on arrête aux gens de
qu'on arrête de dire aux gens que voilà,
ils sont assistés, ils sont inégaux, ils
sont victimes d'une inégalité parce
qu'en gros, c'est ça le discours tu
ambiance, c'est on est il y a plein de
gens qui sont victimes d'inégalité ou de
discrimination. Le mot discrimination
est encore pire parce que ça voudrait
dire par exemple aux employeurs que les
employeurs n'ont plus le droit de
choisir leurs employés en fait. Parce
que il y a qu'est-ce quoi de plus
discriminant que de choisir les la
personne avec qui tu vas travailler ? Tu
vois, c'est ça s'appelle la liberté. La
liberté d'entreprendre, c'est d'abord la
liberté de recruter qui tu veux et et
non merci, j'ai pas besoin de de ratio
ESG ou je sais pas quoi. Il y a que les
D'ailleurs, il y a des études récentes
qui ont prouvé qu'il y a que les grosses
boîtes qui ont les moyens de faire de la
diversité et encore quand elles le font,
elles en payent le prix. Exemple, Boeing
avec les avions qui tombent et ils ont
ils sont revenus sur leur politique de
diversité. Je parle il y a d'autres il y
a d'autres choses aussi euh que les
avions qui tombent, les portes qui
s'ouvrent et enfin dans le cas de
Boeing, c'était des avions qui tombent
donc c'est quand même assez radical
comme conséquence si tu veux. Euh donc
je donc permets-moi quand même de le
souligner mais mais
franchement c'est ces histoires
d'inégalité, ça rejoint les les débats
sur la diversité. Oui, la l'espèce
humaine, il y a de la diversité donc il
y a des inégalités. Seb qui va faire le
diable ? Oui, parce que la question
était pas l'inégalité de revenu, elle
était l'inégalité de richesse et donc
d'accumulation. Ou il y a une autre
réponse à porter, même si j'adhère tout
à fait à ce que vient de dire Pierre,
c'est que euh effectivement euh il y a
une accumulation des richesses, il y a
une disproportion énorme entre le gars
qui travaille et le milliardaire et
cette disproportion a la tendance à
énormément croître. Et ça, c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'effet quantillon. C'est
un problème monétaire. C'està dire que
celui qui s'enrichit, c'est celui qui
est sous le robinet monétaire. L'exemple
Drahi Drahi a emprunté de l'argent plus
qu'il était capable de d'emprunter avec
rien. En gros, il a emprunté des
milliards pour acheter des boîtes.
Voilà. Donc ça parce qu'il était ce
qu'on appelle sous le robinet monétaire.
Quand Bernard Arna va à la banque, il
emprunte de l'argent à prix négatif lui
à tout négatif parce qu'il est sous le
robinet monétaire. C'est quoi ta source
? Enfin, c'est c'est lui ma source,
c'est lui hein. C'est lui. Tu lis les
articles de journaux où il s'exprime
Bernard Arnaud dès 2012, il explique que
l'argent ne grimme pas jusqu'au ciel,
que actuellement on est dans un vrai
problème, que il a accès à autant
d'argent qu'il veut gratuit, on le paye
pour emprunter et que tout ça va finir
en catastrophe. Ça fait 10 ans, 15 ans
qu'il l'annonce. Voilà. Mais lui, il a
conscience d'être sous le revenaire et
donc il a parfaitement conscience de
l'effet quantillon. Et évidemment euh
dès lors que tu as pas de planche
habillée avec Bitcoin, que tu es limité,
qu'on peut imaginer, c'est notre propos,
que ça va devenir un étalon, une
référence monétaire qui évitera euh
cette gapgie monétaire, cette planche
habillée qui qui imprime à fond, euh ça
va arrêter cette inégalité systématique
que crée l'effet
quantillon. Je reviens, je reviens ce
que sur ce que tu disais Pierre.
Tu habites dans un quartier malfamé.
Pourtant tes parents ils bossent comme
des
chiens et mais tu tu bosses bien à
l'école. Tu mets un CV avec ton ton
adresse de quartier
malfamé. Tu as beau Tu as beau être le
premier à l'école, ça devient compliqué
de te faire identifier avec ton quartier
malfamé. Tu vois Seb a bien expliqué la
différence entre inégalité de recherche
et inégalité de Ouais. Qu'est-ce que tu
en penses de ça ? J'en pense que s'il y
a des quartiers comme tu dis malfamés,
c'est qu'il y a un problème de libation
du pays. Il y a des quartiers où moi je
peux pas aller, par exemple, ces
quartierslà, je peux pas y aller. Donc
en tant qu'entrepreneur, c'est comme si
tu me disais "Tu peux recruter un
français mais tu peux recruter
quelqu'un, euh je sais pas moi, dans un
pays lointain que je connais pas." Bah
non, ces quartiers là sont pour moi
comme un pays lointain que je connais
pas parce que et encore le pays lointain
que je connais pas, je peux encore
prendre l'avion pour y aller en sécurité
si ça se trouve. Alors que là, on parle
de quartier où je vais pas aller juste
parce que ma sécurité sera pas assurée.
Donc tu comprends quand tu as compris
ça, tu comprends bien que tu vas pas
demander à un employeur de d'être neutre
sur euh les quartiers en question parce
que le le pays est tellement fragmenté
aujourd'hui que ces enclaves sont pour
moi des pays étrangers puisque je peux
plus y aller. Et là et la frontière,
elle est pas tenue par des douaniers
français, elle est tenue par des
dealers. Donc voilà, c'est le trafic.
Donc donc la réponse si tu veux, elle
est là. C'est que tu es arrivé à un
point où on parle même plus de mais je
suis dans un bah oui, tuas tu es dans un
écosystème, une économie, ces gens qui
ont créé ces quartiers, bah demande-leur
des comptes peut-être justement. Mais tu
peux pas parce que c'est c'est des
dictateurs. En fait, la fragmentation du
pays, c'est pire que ça. C'est que non
seulement c'est des c'est des enclaves
où tu peux pas aller, mais en plus c'est
des enclaves non démocratiques parce
qu'il y a pas de débat dans ces dans ces
quartiers pour changer la situation dans
ces quartiers. Si tu m'autorises à être
maximaliste. Bien sûr. Imagine-toi euh
euh moi je vais aller sur une île de
milliardaire, c'est pas très
démocratique. Alors tu me diras, je
pourrais peut-être me payer un billet
d'avion pour mettre le pied le pied sur
mais quand quand je vais vouloir acheter
mon panny à 24 € ça va être compliqué.
C'est pas la même chose mais dans
l'autre sens.
Je suis pas sûr de te suivre dans le
sens que en fait la richesse, si on
parle d'accumulation de richesse, c'est
quoi ? C'est la c'est la liberté. En
fait, quand tu as la richesse, tu as ce
qu'on appelle l'optionnalité,
c'est-à-dire tu peux décider comment tu
utilises ton temps, où tu vas aller et
cetera. C'est ça la rich. Time code.
Pardon ? Tu as vu le film Time Code ? Ça
me dit rien. Tu
devrais en plus avec un un chanteur.
D'accord. Je je je fais très attention
avant de dépenser de ou 3 heures de
montant avant de regarder un film. Donc,
je retiens ce que tu me dis parce que je
regarde pas de film sans recommandation
en fait.
Donc ta recommandation va m'inciter
peut-être à le regarder. Mais en tout
cas, je voulais juste dire que les les
débats sur la richesse et tout ça et les
inégalités sont des débats sur la
liberté. Donc moi je voudrais je je et
la responsabilité. C'est qu'en gros
commençons par poser des principes de
liberté, de responsabilité et après
effectivement chacun recevra en fonction
de sa contribution à la société. Et
c'est tout à fait respectable d'être SDF
et de dire "Moi, je veux pas
contribuer." Mais à ce moment-là, il y a
il y a une responsabilité à assumer
aussi euh de de dormir sous une tente
qué. Et moi, je j'ai pas de jugement
moral sur quelqu'un qui fait ça. Je dis
c'est son choix de liberté. Il a jamais
voulu se mettre au service des autres en
fait cette personne. Il a juste voulu
être libre. C'est respectable. Le lion
dans la savane, il a une vie de chien
par rapport au lion qui est aux eau, qui
est nourri tous les jours dans sa cage.
Voilà, il y a l'équilibre, c'est
peut-être entre les deux, mais il y a
les deux extrêmes dans la nature. Donc
pourquoi pas dans la nature humaine. Tu
es dans la savane, Pierre ?
Je suis dans le un bocal avec des
requins, des lions dirigés par des
annes. Euh question internet, dans vos
discours, tout semble bien et tout
semble beau. C'est la solution. Bon
soit. Mais ces derniers temps nous
exposent régulièrement une solution
miracle seulement quelques temps plus
tard à la peinture sfrite et on découvre
sous la belle peinture une vague
fumisterie qui profite toujours au même.
Ceux qui
commencent la partie avec la banque, tu
n'auras jamais attends ceux qui
commencent la partie avec Ah ouais, ceux
qui commencent la partie avec une banque
que tu n'auras jamais.
Ça veut dire quoi ? Je l'ai lu tel
attention où l'arcène tu as des poètes.
Tu as des poètes. J'imagine que ça je
sens une opposition de base au principe
du Bitcoin. Ça ça me va. Ça fait 15 ans
que Seb et moi on voit des gens comme ça
qui veulent pas adhérer. Comme disait
Satoshi, on va si tout vous n'avez pas
compris, je vais pas perdre mon temps à
vous expliquer parce qu'effectivement
l'information est disponible. Donc
j'inviterai à cette personne à étudier
Bitcoin avant de se lancer dans des
jugements moraux sur des gens comme moi
qui sont impliqués dedans. Nous, c'est
juste qu'on a sa et moi, on a on a
étudié les fonctionnements de l'euro et
de Bitcoin. Et sur la base de cette
cette étude là, on a conclu que Bitcoin
ça avait un avenir et que ça servait à
quelque chose et qu'il y avait des des
externalités positive pour la société.
Maintenant, si les gens partent du
principe que il y a que le monopole
monétaire qui qui est valable et que
tous ceux qui essayent de le contester
sont des bandits, moi je
personnellement, j'ai arrêté de passer
du temps avec ces gens-là. Je juste
étudier la question puis revenir. On en
parle quand vous l'aurez étudiez. Bah
c'est juste que vous êtes dans
l'idéologie et moi ça m'intéresse pas de
discuter avec un idéologue parce que
l'idéologue n'écoute pas pour discuter,
il écoute pour répondre, pour présenter
des objections. Il écoute pas pour
apprendre, il écoute pas pour discuter.
Donc ces discussions avec des idéologues
ne m'intéressent pas. Et et
heureusement, il y a plein de gens qui
ont une ouverture d'esprit et euh et
c'est pour ça que tu veux pas être
député, je crois. Je crois alors oui,
c'est un autre sujet. Oui, je crois que
la question était sincère. Je vous ai
compris de la question qui était un peu
tournée de manière poétique, c'était que
tout revenait au early adopteur. Si ce
que j'ai cru comprendre ça comme ça moi.
Ceux qui avaient compris le truc avant
les autres ont raflé la mise. On entend
ça souvent hein. Faut bien comprendre
que ceux qui ont découvert Bitcoin comme
Pierre au tout début la plupart ils ont
tout revendu 2 ou 3 ans après parce que
ça avait déjà fait x 10 hein. Donc
contrairement à ce qu'on pense, les gars
qui avaient 10000 Bitcoin en 2011, la
plupart il leur en reste deux ou trois
parce que ils les ont vendu quand ça a
atteint 10 dollars, puis quand ça
atteint 100 dollars, puis quand ça
atteint 1000 dollars. Ils ont acheté une
pizza. Ils ont acheté une pizza pour
voilà quand ça atteint 10000 dollars,
ils en avaient plus du tout. Question
internet. Faut-il à la manière
d'alcatras réhabiliter et fort boyard ?
On a déjà la réponse. On connaît la
réponse. Non. Comment des questions
amusant
beaucoup trop petit ? Question internet.
Comment justifier éthiquement la
politique pénitentiaire du Salvador qui
a permis une réduction spectaculaire de
la criminalité liée au gang mais au prix
de détention massive incluant incluant
potentiellement 10 à 35 % d'erreurs
judiciaires. Déjà, quelle est sa source
? 10 à 35 % d'erreur judiciaire avec des
innocents incarcérés sans procès
équitable ni garantie procédurale.
Alors ça c'est ce qu'on ça c'est
hallucinant parce que tu as des gens qui
ont jamais mis un pied au Salvador ni
même en Amérique du Sud ni même qu'on
vraiment étudié la question mais ils ont
ça ils en sont sûr parce que ils ont lu
libé le monde et ils ont vu le truc dans
surarté 10 à 35 % d'erreurs
judiciair on marche sur la tête il y a
aucune preuve de ça le Salvador a pas
inventé des innocents en prison il y en
a toujours et il y en a partout on
estime qu'aux États-Unis il y a 6 %
d'innocents en prison
Donc ce qu'on sait c'est sur 75000
personnes qui ont été arrêtées dans le
cadre de la lutte contre les gangs, il y
en a 8000 qui ont été immédiatement
remis en liberté. Donc ce qui validerait
les 10 % 12 % d'innocents qui sont
emprisonnés dans ces filets. Mais c'est
le prix à payer. Les gars, ils restent
pas longtemps en prison hein. 10 jours
après, ils sont ressortis. N'empêche que
90 % de la population est d'accord avec
ça. Moi, j'aurais tendance à dire qui
aurait intérêt à maintenir en prison des
innocents. Je pense que Bouquellé, il
est pas plus bête ou plus malfaisant
qu'un autre et il veut surtout résoudre
le problème de la sécurité. Il ferait on
a tendance à faire de la place pour les
vrais criminels que garder des innocents
en prison. Donc cette accusation me
paraît plutôt d'ordre idéologique.
Encore une fois, c'est l'idéologie de
que la prison ça marche pas. Donc ils
vont trouver toutes sortes d'arguments
pas forcément documentés. Je sais pas
quelle est sa source. effectivement à
cette personne mais ça va contre le bon
sens qui est de dire quand les gens si
un gouvernement comme Bouquellé qui veut
résoudre le problème de la sécurité met
les gens en prison c'est pour résoudre
le problème de la sécurité donc c'est
pas pour des raisons idéologiques parce
que justement c'est pas un idéologue. Si
c'était un idéologue, il dirait comme
ces gens-là, on met pas les gens en
prison parce que c'est pas bon, c'est
pas éthique, c'est pas question
internet. Défendre la justice et les
lois quand elles doivent protéger les
mieux nanti. C'est un problème pour la
démocratie ou pas ? Bah les lois doivent
s'appliquer pour tout le monde. Pourquoi
protégerait juste les plus lentilles ?
Comprends pas le sens de la question. me
fait financer par une puissance
étrangère en Libye ou peut-être pas et
j'ai un bracelet électronique parce que
j'ai fait des écoutes qu'il fallait pas
et je vais aux échelles. Séchelle c'est
bien les échelles vous voyez tranquille
que il y a pas un proverbe que vous
soyez vous connaissez le proverbe. Si si
la voilà c'est oui la question la
question de l'accès au à une un avocat
compétent et tout ça bien sûr que si on
on a de l'argent on peut payer un un
avocat un commis d'office bon ouais non
non mais on est d'accord sur le ça c'est
incontestable la fontaine a toujours
raison selon que vous soyez puissant ou
mis la justice sera pas la même. Ça
c'est sûr. C'est les limites du droit de
ça a toujours été comme
ça et c'est malheureux hein parce qu'à
notre époque ça devrait
plus pour le crâne là. Est-ce que vous
avez un sujet step qui lève le le C'est
toi qui nous bon c'est moi qui bour le
crâne. Bah oui c'est toi qui nous un peu
làhaut. C'est toi qui nous fait bosser.
On arrive à la fin de on arrive à la fin
de notre de notre interview. Est-ce que
vous avez un sujet qu'on a pas abordé
que vous souhaiteriez en quelques mots
aborder ou est-ce que je passe aux deux
questions euh qui nous font qui font la
pâte de la chaîne ?
C'est bon pour moi ? Non, je pense qu'on
a couvert beaucoup de beaucoup de sujets
en fait aujourd'hui. Ouais. Alors là, on
va poser pas une question, mais je vous
demande à chacun de me conseiller et de
conseiller à la à la communauté trois
livres qui ont compté pour vous dans la
construction de votre raisonnement, dans
l'arborescence de de votre raisonnement
et qui tous les jours peuvent aider les
gens. Pierre, alors tu as pas le droit
de conseiller ton livre, c'est interdit.
Non, non, bien sûr. Comment il s'appelle
ton livre ? Euh, l'énergie face cachée
de la monnaie. Allez, conseille trois
trois autres bouquins. Voilà. Euh,
j'aurais envie de conseiller
euh le le le livre du taoïme de voilà de
La Tao Shesin. Euh c'est un livre sur le
livre de base du taoïme pour euh que les
gens se familiarisent avec une
philosophie orientale accessible. Je les
je les envoie pas sur tout Confuscius ou
voilà des des des œuvres qui sont très
très longues à lire. Il y a il y a des
gens qui ont écrit aussi sur les les
philosophies orientales. Peut-être je
pourrais t'envoyer les liens mais qui
vulgarise quelque part ces philosophies
orientales. Ce serait vraiment ma
recommandation de lecture, c'est dire
s'intéresser à ces philosophies
puisqu'elles m'ont aidé moi à
appréhender le monde et et j'ai trouvé
qu'elle raisonnait très bien avec cette
thèse que j'ai sur l'énergie comme
constituant fondamental de l'univers et
de notre nature comme en
fait quelque
part concurrent comme concept concurrent
du concept divin puisque comme l'a dit
si si on lignit par exemple il celui qui
a tué la science
Dieu si on lit nich effectivement on
trouve sa définition de Dieu, c'est
quasiment la la définition de l'énergie.
C'est-à-dire elle est partout, elle elle
est pas elle a été incréée, elle est
partout, elle est omnipotente. Bah de
facto, si tu lis mon livre, tu vas
pouvoir conclure que je suis plutôt
atât. D'ailleurs, ça peut être AT ou
aposta ? Alors à d'ailleurs je peux
recommander dans 2e livre parce que il
faut tr je je vais recommander un 2è
c'est l'athéisme expliqué euh par euh
euh Paul euh Paul de
Sal euh c'est un livre assez peu connu
mais c'est euh l'athéisme expliqué et
c'est euh extrêmement bien bien fait euh
qui est euh je dirais quelque part
effectivement une critique du concept de
Dieu. C'est c'est pas c'est pas une une
recommandation. Évidemment, les gens qui
sont croyants, ils resteront sans
d'autres croyants. Mais au moins, il y a
une critique du concept de Dieu. En tant
que concept, l'énergie est un concept
aussi, hein. Il faut bien comprendre
qu'on parle là de concept, c'est de
choses abstraites dans lesquelles les
gens vont construire à partir desquels
les gens vont construire une
compréhension du réel, hein. Donc là,
c'est donc le le 3è livre en 3e,
qu'est-ce que je pourrais ? Il y en a
plein, il y en a tellement. C'est plutôt
dur de dur de choisir. Euh mais euh sur
Bitcoin, évidemment, j'aime beaucoup
Andreas Anton Poulos. Je je je
recommanderai l'internet of money,
l'internet de l'argent par André Santono
Poulos, c'est une suite de conférence
donc c'est facile à lire. On prend une
petite conférence une après l'autre. il
aborde différents sujets et quand on a
lu Andreas Santopos, on a une bonne
compréhension de Bitcoin à la fin. Donc
ça peut aider les gens à appréhender le
sujet de manière relativement facile.
Euh c'est est-ce que tu crois en Dieu ?
Je suis até.
Personne n'est parfait. Je te dirais.
C'est ça. Oui. Mais bon moi à la
différence l'avocat à la différence de
certains até je pense pas que les
croyants croient en un ami imaginaire.
J'ai du respect pour les gens qui
croient en Dieu. Moi, c'est quelque
chose qui m'a pas touché. Euh mais je
comprends très bien
surtout ce mépris pour les gens qui
croient en Dieu quand on n'y croit pas,
c'est assez facile, hein. C'est nous, on
est on est dans la science, c'est
quelque chose qui qui est complètement
délirant d'imaginer qu'il y a un gars
là-haut qui vit dans le ciel qui nous
aime mais qui va nous mettre en enfer si
on fait pas bien les choses. Enfin, tu
connais le sketch le sketch de John euh
Caroline.
Voilà.
Excellent. Et euh mais il vous aime et
euh non, moi j'ai du respect pour ça
parce que c'est peut-être juste que j'ai
pas encore les l'esprit assez ouvert et
en tout cas je vois des gens euh plus
intelligents et plus cultivés que moi
qui sont croyants. Donc ça me suffit à
être humble vis-à-vis de ça même. Tu as
trois bouquins à nous conseiller. Bah la
Bible ça moi je l'ai lu, tu vois, pour
essayer de comprendre ce qu'il y avait
dedans. Laquelle ? Moi j'ai vu la
version moderne. Elle est en livre de
poche. C'est ça. Pratiquement. Ouais.
J'ai lu ça quand j'étais jeune, hein. Je
te vois bien habillé. Mais j'ai lu le
Coran aussi et j'ai lu aussi la Torah.
Enfin, je me suis pas en entier hein. Le
Coran c'est waouh etion originale mais
la Bible, j'ai tout lu parce que j'ai lu
ça je sais pas quand j'avais 12 13 14
ans sur plusieurs années. Évidemment, je
conseillerai le le bests seller du
moment qui est l'énergie face cachée de
la monnaie de Pierre Noisa. Ça n'est pas
préparé.
un très très très bon bouquin que
j'avais déjà conseillé à mon dernier
passage. C'est vrai, c'est vrai, c'est
vrai. Et euh en fait, envie qu'il achète
des parts de ta boîte ou quoi ? Non, j'y
ai pas réfléchi. Euh non euh non, pas
spécialement, pas spécialement. Non,
mais c'est un ami Pierre et tu vois lui
cite euh Anton Poulos. Moi je peux citer
Anton Poulos qui est un de mes mentors,
mais je peux citer aussi Pierre Noisard
qui m'a amené au Bitcoin qui était ma
seule parce queil dit nous avec Seb mais
pas du tout. Lui, il a commencé en 2009
et moi j'ai commencé en 2016. Donc moi,
la matière que j'avais à cette
époque-là, enfin en 2015, je me suis
vraiment intéressé au Bitcoin, en 2015,
il y avait trois bouquins en français
euh enfin trois sources en français dont
dont Pierre Noisa. Je peux te couper.
Donc c'est Morard. Tu me fais tu me
tends une courte échelle Pierre quand tu
es en
2009 que tu
sens que ça fait frétiller ton ton
cortex que ton cervelet est entre la
peur et l'excitation.
L'excitation. Tu as pas l'impression de
te sentir seul ? Ah oui, bah c'est
clairement euh c'était pas gagné hein.
Donc euh forcément c'était plus une
idée. Comment tu as fait pour résister
aux insultes, au fait que En 2009, il y
en avait pas parce que j'étais pas
public là-dessus. Je suis devenu public
euh euh j'ai commencé à en parler
vraiment à mon entourage et publiquement
en 2011. Donc j'ai attendu. Et pourquoi
en 2011 ? Parce qu'en fait en 2011, j'ai
en lisant la presse, je me suis dit
[__] ce truc est en train de marcher.
Notamment en mars, je me souviens au
début de 2011, il y a eu un un pic comme
ça de de C'est ça. Ouais. dans les
magazines avait Force, je crois que
c'était Force Magazine qui en a parlé.
Je me suis dit le jour où Force Magazine
en parle, c'est que le truc ça y est,
c'est bon, ça marche en fait. Donc
évidemment 2010, on pouvait voir les
prémisses, ça commençait à côté. Donc on
voyait le le cours qui commençait à à
frittiller un petit peu. Mais en 2011,
c'était devenu très clair. Donc
effectivement mais je me sentais pas
insulté en 2009 parce que personne j'en
parlais pas et personne n'en parlait à
l'époque. En tout cas, c'est trois
bouquins du mo tu'en a donné déjà deux.
Ouais, je dirais ben du coup comme j'y
ai pas réfléchi ça, j'étais en train d'y
penser. Je pense à à Zadig de Voltaire.
C'est un livre qui m'a beaucoup marqué.
Pierre, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations et Seb, un conseil pour les
jeunes générations. Moi, le même que
celui que j'avais donné la fois
précédente. Euh, tu vois, on a une
question sur le l'égalité des de
richesse, par exemple. Arrêtez de vous
focaliser sur la l'égalité et pensez à
votre liberté. C'est vraiment on est
dans un monde où les libertés sont en
train de de disparaître à bas bruit et
donc soyez très vigilant de ça. Euh
Pierre disait que les avoir la richesse,
c'était une optionalité, une possibilité
d'être libre. Moi, je me suis pas rendu
compte de ça jusqu'à peut-être l'âge de
30 ans. Pour moi, je méprisais l'argent
et tout ce qui touchait à l'argent. Et
effectivement, l'argent te donne une
capacité d'échapper à une dictature tout
simplement. Tu voulais manger des
cornflakes aussi ? Tu connais pas manger
des cornflex ? Moi je connais pas. Tu
voulais devenir astronaute ? Non plus.
Non plus. Non plus. Non non plus. Je
t'enverrai la vidéo, tu comprendras.
Merci. Je veux bien. Pierre, tu veux
leur donner un conseil ? Alors non pas
un conseil mais juste leur dire que
effectivement étudier euh des matières
fondamentales comme les mathématiques et
la philosophie, c'est ça qui va les
aider dans leur chemin de vie. Plus que
des choses peut-être plus à la mode et
cetera, revenir aux
fondamentaux. Voilà. Donc les maths et
la philosophie suivant leur appétence,
c'est deux deux matières qui peuvent
étudier et qui qui contribueront sans
doute à les rendre heureux. Mais encore
une fois, c'est plus c'est
plus un retour d'expérience qu'une qu'un
conseil. Ça veut rajouter quelque chose
? Non, juste j'adhère pour le côté
philosophique, c'est pour ça que je je
propose Zadic de Voltaire pour moi qui
est une ouverture à la philosophie
totale avec la découverte de la
providence et ça permet de relativiser
un peu des peines qu'on peut avoir quand
on perd des gens, des choses comme ça.
Enfin, la philosophie évidemment permet
de grandir beaucoup.
Pierre Sébastien, merci.
Merci à toi. Sky.
[Musique]